ebook
several programs will appear and you can
watch them all online
and now book tv's monthly in-depth
program with best-selling fiction author
david ignatius the washington post
columnist has written many novels
including agents of innocence blood
money body of lies and most recently the
quantum spy this is part of our 2018
special fiction edition of in-depth
david ignatius what's the premise of the
quantum spy
premise of the quantum spy is that the
united states is locked in a new
manhattan project race
to build a piece of technology that is
if it can be built world-changing and
that is a quantum computer
and our principal rival in that race is
china
what i've told you this far is simply
the facts uh the quantum spy is a novel
that
imagines the characters who'd be
involved in an intelligence
battle to see who can steal the others
secrets
about this world-changing technology
it's principally this the story of my
hero harris chang
american of chinese descent who's a ci
officer who is asked to penetrate the
chinese intelligence service and in the
process
learns
things about himself things about the
cia things about how the world works
that
shake him up to his foundations and
we also see in this novel how the
chinese intelligence service
not so familiar to readers of spy
fiction we all feel we've been in moscow
center with carla and you know the
russian
spy world is very familiar to us chinese
not so much so one of the pleasures for
me in writing up for people in reading
the quantum spies it takes us into the
world of the ministry of state security
the very secretive chinese intelligence
agency that is the principal antagonist
in this book for the cia
how much of it is true or real let's go
with real i always uh say um in
the prefaces to my books that
they exist in an imagined world
i sometimes tell people if you take any
book i write and think it's a recipe for
how to bake a cake you're going to end
up with a mud pie because it's got all
sorts of things thrown in
that said i try to do a lot of research
for every one of my novels the quantum
spy is my tenth novel i researched it
for many months
i went to the
computer laboratories where quantum
computers are being experimented with in
one case where one has been built
i travel to every place that's mentioned
in the book and looked at it and thought
about it i studied the chinese
intelligence service
in all sorts of different ways so
my my answer would be that it's a novel
story is imaginary the characters don't
exist in real life but it is drawn from
real life
it's as real as i could make it be
and still be a work of fiction well one
of the conflicts in the book is about
science and whether it should be open
and shared and you write that science
has no flags
science
shouldn't have have flags um the problem
in this area that i was writing about
where you have this
super powerful technology the reason the
reason quantum computing is so important
is because if you built a quantum
computer it could shred any system of
encryption ever devised
it would essentially render all of your
adversaries most secret messages
documents information
uh your your own so uh you know it it it
has that real purpose
in in in the world
when it comes to quantum computing
is it the future
quantum computing uh
is is coming at us fast
in my book i describe a technology that
is a kind of quantum computing the
purists say it's actually quantum
annealing and i won't bore your viewers
with the details of the difference but
it's not quite a quantum computing but
it assembles qubits
the standard computer has bits that are
either zero or one famously they're
either on or off and a quantum computer
is made up of what are called qubits
that strange that sounds are
zero and one at the same time
they have this ambiguous state
and that means that as you assemble
these qubits as you entangle them to use
the phrase that technologists use you
begin to build a computer that because
it goes in every direction
simultaneously is vastly more powerful
than any supercomputer ever built it
said that
a problem that would take thousands of
years even for the most powerful
supercomputers could be done in a few
seconds with a quantum computer just
because of the power of these of these
qubits
so
whoever gets that technology is going to
have an instrument that will be
potentially world changing it also can
change our world in lots of other ways
in terms of discovering
drugs or new materials material science
anything that involves lots of
computation lots of simulation
these computers will be able to do in a
in an entirely different way and that's
why everybody's so excited about it it
used to be said that this was 20 years
out you know if possible then people
began to say well maybe it's 10 years
out the most recent estimates i've heard
are that maybe it's five years out and
as i mentioned there is a company based
in vancouver british columbia that has
built this quantum annealer that has
assembled two thousand qubits and can do
very powerful calculations
in some areas so
when you talk to people who do
technology they get excited about this
but nobody can give you a precise
prediction about just why it's coming
you asked earlier about about
classification
a lot of this computer research is is
open
obviously our i.t companies the
companies that changed the world google
microsoft had proprietary limits on
their technology they they owned it but
it was not classified there weren't
controls the whole point was to just
move it out as quickly as you could
with something that has so many military
applications like quantum computing
there has been for
this has been going on for 20 years an
effort to take some
of the most sensitive uh technologies
involved in building a quantum computer
and do some of that research
with classification
the in it the first way i found out
about this was disclosure of the nsa's
secret black budget as is called and
there was a big a chunk of funding for
quantum computing that's when i first
thought wow there's something here that
was back in 2014.
so uh
there is a battle going on between
scientists who want the most open world
possible where we should we share
information ideas where our labs have
the smartest graduate students from
china from russia wherever they come
from we don't worry about control of
information and others who say this is
just too valuable to our country that
you that you wouldn't have brought
germans into los alamos during the
manhattan project research it was too
sensitive so they they argue we need
controls and that's as you as you said
one of the issues that's debated in the
book and that's one of the themes in the
quantum spy about harris chang is that
his americanism is questioned
harris chang our our hero
american chinese descendant grew up in
flagstaff arizona as he says at one
point i bleed red white and blue
uh served in the army in iraq
is recruited in into this into this cia
feels entirely american he went to west
point he
never occurred to him that his ethnic
background would be subject to
manipulation and he finds in the course
of the book that both for the chinese
who try to manipulate him using his
ancestry and for some americans in the
intelligence community who doubt him
because of his ancestry it ends up being
central to his experience deeply
upsetting for him as a as a person
and that's really the arc of his story
is coming to realize that um that people
see him in a way he doesn't see himself
and that
by the end of the book in ways that i'll
let readers describe
he is the quantum spy
david ignatius has that been true in the
intelligence community since the 40s or
whenever that
somebody's
nationality or their
heritage
can affect how they're viewed
well i think our intelligence community
has always been eager to use the
richness of our national fabric
to draw people who speak languages who
have cultural skills
often some of the case officers who work
the soviet file would have
russian or ukrainian east european
backgrounds
often
in the middle east people who speak
arabic have a a native fluency
through their families or other
experiences were drawn into that that
part of the agency's operation so
it's always been been a plus i think the
the danger is when people feel that
they're just being seed in
seen in stereotypical ways
as as the arab american you know and
he's good at this set of things but not
that
that i think there's been a similar
problem with with gender i think women
for decades felt that although they were
given
responsible roles that they weren't
given the heart of what the cia does
they weren't allowed
encouraged to go out and recruit spies
which is how you make your
mark in the cia
and they felt limited
their careers were stunted that's
another theme that weaves through this
novel as a
woman who who felt that she she was
in a sense robbed of the
success
and experience she might have had as an
intelligence officer because of her
gender
ends up having a deep rage about that
and that is another engine that drives
the plot of this book so with a novel
like this do you start with the
conclusion then work backwards
you really start
i think with
the
idea the theme that you want to play
with i got interested in quantum
computing i'm always looking for
something that's new i i love
as a journalist i love to go out and
report and find new information so i got
interested in quantum computing and i
saw that the chinese were our principal
rivals that that interested me but it
wasn't until i i could see the
characters in space
it wasn't until i could see harris chang
in a
hotel room in singapore i remember i
literally started writing this book
after a trip to singapore i was coming
on the back on the plane this long plane
ride because suddenly i understood where
the ball would start rolling in this
tail and it would start in a in a hotel
room in singapore so i think for the for
the writer it's this this process of
taking the themes uh making those themes
alive and the characters understanding
uh the places those characters are gonna
are gonna are gonna inhabit um and then
to be honest a essential
thing in writing this book and every
book i've written is is rewriting
you get a first draft in which you've
you know
done your first kind of rough sketch
and then you you need to go in
ruthlessly and look at what works and
what doesn't the the passages that
really are alive the characters who were
fully developed and the ones that just
don't work and so you need in that
period
people who be really honest with you and
say david
this just isn't there yet you got to go
back and do it again that person for me
principally
in my recent books been my wife eve
who uh you know the hardest thing in the
world is you've seen your husband
slaving away and he's just yeah he's so
proud he's got the first draft done and
he gives it to you like a puppy and so
uh i would say you know eve is this what
do you think and
she would read it carefully and say
i just don't i just don't think it's
there yet i just don't think this
character is fully believable so you go
back and rewrite it and then hopefully
you get another honest evaluation and i
because i think that's
the we
even the very best writers are capable
of writing
stuff that's just you know not not very
good it's not real
and we need people who will who will
tell us that the things we may love in
our books
just aren't there yet do it again
so i i've learned over time to value the
people who
will say that to me directly not good
enough
harris chang john vandell kate sturm
denise ford mike flanagan some of the
characters in the quantum spy which what
are those names projecting
those names are projecting uh
a
diverse agency the cia is is one
in terms of every variable
there are a lot of women who work now at
the agency in every role um i think
one thing that really has changed about
the cia was once thought to be an ivy
league playground
it was thought that basically yale was
the feeder school to the cia
it's more diverse in that way people
from
every uh
educational background
um see is looking for the unconventional
uh
interests and backgrounds that they will
make for good operatives
you know i i think there's a blue collar
side of the cia
and a white collar side i think that
kate sturm who was the head of support
in my book really important part of the
cia
not often recognized but they're the
ones who you know rent the safe houses
and run the airplanes and send out the
shooters to guard the case officers they
do all long glamorous
stuff you gotta get get done if you're
going to conduct intelligence operations
they're the blue collar workers and they
and they and they kind of carry
themselves that way they often got a
chip on their shoulder they're really
interesting people one thing i've done
more recently in my books is try to
explore those people and how they think
well david ignatius with those
characters they seem to have unlimited
safe houses unlimited money
unlimited resources is
is that based on real life
i think that the cia doesn't suffer f
for resources it suffers sometimes from
from from ideas
it suffers from our difficulty as a
country in operating in truly
clandestine ways and as a people
americans aren't great at
keeping secrets we're not great at
telling lies um you know there's a kind
of natural straightforwardness to the
american character i think
um
the cia in the period when american
power was
strongest
you know in the cold war years
had the wind at its back
everybody around the world wanted to be
america's friend so our
enormously powerful economy is the
engine of global prosperity i once
joked that in beirut it was hard to find
a person who either wasn't a ci contact
or didn't want to be seen as one because
that that was the coin of the realm i'm
a friend of america today
people are much more reluctant to be
seen as friends of america it can get
you killed today rather than help make
your fortune so i think where we had the
wind in our back uh we now are
going into a pretty
uh strong headwind
uh it's it's harder to find people who
are willing to take those risks
when the us does find them we're not
always as good as we should be in
protecting them protecting the secrets
that they
are sharing with with the u.s government
so i think that
i've been writing
this is my 10th novel and
my first one was published more than 30
years ago
over that time what i've seen is an
agency that i think
has has lost its way a little bit but
really struggles most of all with the
way the world has changed where america
was super powerful and everybody wanted
to be our friend today as we see looking
around the world we're not super
powerful we have stronger rivals and
everybody doesn't want to be our friend
we have we have more enemies than we
used to well what i've noticed in your
books is that there's not necessarily a
clear-cut good guy bad guy scenario
i think
spy novels always as we say are painted
in shades of gray and the moral
ambiguities that intelligence work is
all about
um
are are the kind of basic uh uh you know
ambience of the of this of the spy novel
in in in my in my books um
the operators who in a sense are most
ruthless and effective
john vandal who was the chief of
uh clandestine operations at the agency
in my new book the quantum spy who just
in terms of being a tough character as
he says it at the end of the book
you know if it's simple ask the state
department to do it
if you want something
complicated and morally complex you know
we're the right people
operators like john vandell
i hope the reader will see as as as
competent professionals
but there are questions that you ask
about about corners that he cuts there
are questions that
uh harris chang the hero of this book
asks more and more
deeply about his colleagues
he just he wonders if um
you know if if they're ruthless to the
point of shattering uh the reason that
he got into the ci in the first place
your first book 1987 it came out agents
of innocence takes place in beirut and
about that book you wrote
it was obvious that the only way i could
share this world of fact
was through fiction what were you
referring to
i had written for the wall street
journal
where i was then middle east
correspondent
a story that was published in
february of 1983.
i had worked on the story for more than
two years
and that front page story
said that the cia the united states
had
recruited
the chief of intelligence of yasser
arafat and the plo at that time the
leading terrorist adversary of the
united states
as a cia asset that he this person had
been enormously
helpful saving thousands of american
lives and had been assassinated
in 1979
by israel which regarded him
with good reason
as a terrorist as somebody who had taken
israeli lives so he won't talk about the
gray zone of intelligence
this case really had it
two months after i published that
article on the front page
the ci officer who would run this
operation whose name was robert ames the
great american hero the subject of a
superb non-fiction book that was
published two years ago called the good
spy
robert ames came to beirut
and he went to visit the cia station at
the american embassy it happened that i
had a meeting with the military attache
that same day i left the embassy about
12 30.
just after one o'clock on that day in
april 1983
the biggest car bomb that anybody had
ever seen in beirut
exploded at the
door of the embassy
i had gone back up the hill i was in my
hotel when i heard just that
roar this
shattering roar of this explosion ran
down the hill
and saw the embassy just shattered i
described it as as if the flesh of the
building had been ripped away you just
saw
the insides
robert ames this
hero had been the ci's leading middle
east specialist
had been killed along with every member
of the ci
station it was in beirut that day
they were all at lunch and happened to
be near where the highest impact of the
bomb was
and in the aftermath of that tragedy
the arabs who had been working with
the u.s on this long-running case
remember
arafat's chief of intelligence had been
in
constant contact with the cia
the people who've been involved in that
who knew about it
needed to talk about it they needed to
grieve
over the loss of this man robert ames
who they really believed in
and i because i've been working on the
story for two years
i was the only american alive a
journalist
in beirut who
they felt they could talk to so people
began coming to me and telling me things
that a journalist just doesn't hear and
shouldn't hear probably
and i began to accumulate this
richness of information about a story
whose basic
outlines i'd already written on the
front page but i began to know so much
more and i thought
what on earth are you going to do with
this
and the answer in the end was
you've got to write a novel i had no
idea how to write a novel i was a
journalist i've been working for the
wall street journal at that point for
what you know eight years
so i sat down
wrote a first draft wrote a second draft
sent it off to
10 publishers was turned down by
everyone
uh finally the publisher
who's still my publisher wwe norton uh
said okay we'll publish agents of
innocence
on condition that should give us a
non-fiction book and they didn't really
want the novel that much either but to
get the non-fiction book that they
thought ignatius the journalist should
write they were willing to buy it to buy
the novels so that's how agents of
innocence was published in 1987
it was although i didn't say it at the
time
essentially a true story from page one
to the end and
the people who are most involved in this
work uh in the plo in the cia and
intelligence agencies in israel all over
the middle east
knew immediately when the book came out
that this was all real
and uh
so the book began to get a real
sort of cachet with readers who knew and
then and then it began to be to be read
it
i've i've teased
people to see i say that they give it
out to
young recruits uh to kind of explain
this is what the business is about i've
had
over over the last 30 years a dozen
ci officers various places around the
world kind of walk up to me and say i
can't tell you who i am but i just want
to say when you know i want to tell my
mom and dad what i really did i sent
them your book and it's it has the
virtue it's just
the basics of what an intelligence
officer does told through the story of
one of the great cases that they ever
ran i mean it was
really executed
by a real professional in the most
ambiguous terrain morally because of the
fact that this plo guy really was an
enemy of israel so
that got me started peter and i just i
never stopped i i
you know i i i taught myself how to
write a novel which i didn't didn't know
how to do
witnessed all those rejection slips that
i got
um and i and i began to uh
learn the craft of writing fiction got
kind of got hooked on it and it's played
off of my journalism ever since over 30
years the things that interest me that i
begin to report about but there's so
much more that i'd like to say
this life as a novelist gave me a chance
to to really unpack the ideas the places
the issues
in a way that i just i
i say at the end of this new book the
quantum spy that i thought 30 years ago
when agents of innocence was published i
would have to choose
whether to be a journalist or a novelist
and i'm glad that i didn't and i really
mean that i'm glad i never had to make
that choice can we draw any straight
lines from your washington post column
national security column
to your novels
you can certainly draw straight lines in
terms of subject matters of interest
in my columns i've written a lot about
iran and those readers in my column no i
visited iran in 2006 again in 2013.
after the 2006 visit i was fascinated by
the iranian nuclear program which was
just becoming an issue of intense
interest
and i thought this is a perfect setting
for a novel so i wrote a novel called
the the increment which was again drawn
on a template of real life but but
imaginary imagining that an iranian
nuclear scientist had been what the cia
calls a virtual walk-in a vw where you
know the cia
its website says if you have something
to tell us here's how to do it
and they get a lot of people coming in
over the transom and they indeed have
had people coming in
from iran
so that's how that novel began uh it
ends up describing
an assault on the iranian
supply chain for their nuclear program
that is eerily like
what we learned to call stuxnet
and uh so it that's one where just
making some lucky guesses i ended up in
terrain that was more factual than i
realized at the time
so you know that's an example where
readers read my columns when i was when
i was there
the
what they didn't know is i was just you
know taking every piece of
kind of pocket litter i could find every
map every every guidebook every you know
restaurant menu and squirreling them all
away and bringing them back home to use
and trying to reconstruct the fictional
iran that would that would be in that
novel
david ignatius has anyone ever s
felt outed
by you by a character in one of your
books
uh people
somebody just joked to me the other day
a former intelligence officer and said
uh you know i'm i'm i'm the real harry
pappas harry pappas is the
principal character in the book i just
described the increment
and i didn't hear anger in that
i heard him
talk about it as it was a bit of a
bragging right
the
my first novel
agents of innocence was about things
that were so sensitive
that when it was published i just didn't
know what the consequences would be
i'd never done this before i knew how
raw it was i just made a decision i'm
gonna i'm gonna get this as right as i
can
and i just i didn't i didn't know what
people would do
uh and initially there was shock
over the years i people sometimes write
that i you know
write the sympathetically about about
the sea ice you know sometimes
that may be so but but over the years i
have written things that have
you know made people's hair stand on end
but i've never had anybody um
i try to be careful about about you know
not taking a character per se and outing
that person uh people's identities are
are secret and they're they are
at risk if those identities are
disclosed so i try to be careful about
that well you've got a former cia
director who blurbed your book but the
bank of fear which came out in 1995.
how'd you get that uh
over the years these books have been
read by a lot of ci officers
my new book the quantum spy has blurbs
from three former directors
um
yeah i i've been shameless in asking
people no matter who they are
tv journalists
you name it
for for blurbs
as
readers
know
all those little quotes on the back page
of the books that you buy
uh us writers work so hard to get and it
it can be embarrassing you know to knock
on somebody's door
uh electronically and say please please
please would you read my book would you
say something nice about it
i made a rule years ago because i felt
it was so difficult to get started that
pretty much anybody who asked me
to write a blurb for a book on a subject
write i mentioned it as a reason to read
it i'll say yes
uh just hoping that i can give somebody
else the start
the boost that i had when i was a young
writer from the people who wrote those
little blurbs including former ci
directors good afternoon and welcome to
book tv on c-span 2 and this is the
kick-off edition of our special fiction
edition year of in-depth david ignatius
is our guest this first month and all
year long will be having fiction writers
best-selling fiction writers on the
in-depth program to talk about their
books
for david ignatius the numbers are
202-748-8200
if you live in the east and central time
zones
748-8201 if you live in the mountain and
pacific time zones and want to
participate in our conversation this
afternoon you can also participate via
social media and that includes facebook
twitter instagram and email
just remember at book tv is our handle
and our email address is booktv
cspan.org as we've mentioned mr ignatius
is a washington post columnist on
national security issues and he's the
author of these 10 books
agents of innocence which we've talked
about came out in 1987
ciro 1991 the bank of fear in 1995 a
firing offense in 1997
the sun king came out in 1999 and then
perhaps you saw the movie body of lies
is a book that came out in 2007
the increment in 2009 blood money 2011
the director in 2014
and the quantum spy
just came out in the last couple of
months
david ignatius your books have moved
from
beirut to iran iraq washington
kind of keeping up with all the threats
that the u.s sees and now we're in china
well i i
i wanted to write about china very
deliberately i think in terms of
national security threats going forward
also opportunities but but let's talk
about threats china needs to be at the
top of people's lists
china has announced
in the pursuit of its president xi
jinping that it it intends to dominate
the commanding heights of technology
by 2030 certainly
sustained that through 2050 and they've
been very specific
and they've tasked their intelligence
service to go out and gather information
okay let's be bought steel secrets that
will help reinforce that position
they're building new weapon systems that
will be able to
challenge america's enormous military
power in
the asia pacific
so
china has set a course that people worry
is going to bring it into a
a collision a military conflict with the
united states i am not somebody who
believes that that's inevitable but i do
think it's time for thoughtful readers
to try to get inside chinese ambitions
in terms of being a world power to get
inside the chinese intelligence service
and how it operates
uh that was again part of the fun of
this book but but but you're quite right
the i do try to look at the things that
i think are going to be the next
big
threat my last book the director was
about how the russians were manipulating
the
you know libertarian underground the
world of wikileaks well when that book
was written people didn't think about it
much we're now in the midst of this huge
mueller investigation but you know if
you go back and read the directory
you'll find some useful guide
posts to where we are now i hope that
people will feel the same way about the
quantum spy as we
get more focused on china and china's
operations they'll see in this book
you know characters
uh settings that that help you
understand what's coming at us that's a
lot of what i like to do in my books is
is to open up the world that i'm
reporting as a columnist in my columns
and these little 750 word nuggets
in a in a much bigger way so people can
really think about about the issues
the cloak and dagger aspects of these
novels
are they true i mean does this stuff
happen
so what fascinated me from my first
novel was the process of recruitment
the way in which i
get someone
to be willing to share secrets with the
united states
how i how i play on that person's vanity
uh needs
uh
vulnerabilities
um
and and draw that person into a secret
relationship
obviously
uh one reason this interests me and also
one reason that i think i'm able to
write about it um
convincingly
is that it's so much like being a
journalist
what i do as a journalist every day is
go out and talk to people people who may
not want think they want to talk to
washington post columnist but over time
gain their trust
as they begin to tell me things that i
think are important for my readers
think about how to protect
them so that they don't suffer for
having share that information
so
that part of the intelligence business
which has nothing to do with the
shoot-'em-up james bond you know
aston martin
crazy technology
that simple part of
identifying the target who knows
something thinking how you make an
approach to that target
having an initial contact and then
slowly reeling that
person in as a potential source that
that interests me and i if you look at
each of my books that process is central
i guess the other thing that's in every
one of my books
is
in some ways the suggestion that the
united states doesn't know enough
about the parts of the world where we
get so deeply involved to take the risks
that we do that's the theme of agents of
innocence my first novel
in some ways it's consistent uh all the
way through to this to this book that we
just
don't know enough to take take risks
our country has gotten in a series of
wars
through the time i've been a journalist
one after the other in the middle east
and i i keep thinking
i wish they knew what the characters in
my novels know
about
how often we're flying blind
and in fact you write and i believe this
is from quantum spy but you're writing
about an agent
who is quote game for anything a
sentiment
not readily heard at the cia
ci is as has has gotten more risk averse
over the decades that i've been i've
been writing about it this idea of
the ci's
rogue elephant doing whatever it wants i
mean that
period
i think really ended with the
investigations in the 1970s it certainly
ended in the investigations that
followed the
practices of of torture see i like to
call it harsh interrogation but let's
let's be honest that followed 911
and
i think ci officers now know that they
can be legally
vulnerable
i think they often take out
legal insurance to protect themselves
against the possibility that they need
that they need counsel and inevitably
that that makes people more careful
about about operations the the uh this
is a a can-do
culture
you never want to be the the person who
says mr president i'm not sure that's a
good idea you say yes sir you know can
you get this done yes sir and so you
know that's that's that's the culture
but i think there is now uh
sir let's
talk to the lawyers before we sign off
on that operation lawyers are a big part
of
ci operations now they always have been
some part but i think they're the bigger
i think that's a really interesting
issue for the current director mike mike
pompeo who said publicly that he'd like
to see the agency be more aggressive
take more risks to gather the secrets
from north korea or china or russia that
we really need to know
when you take more risks the danger of
getting caught increases the danger of
flaps which is the
term of art at the ci increases
and the lawyers are always going to be
there to say not a good idea sir and the
and the and the congressional committees
which now play such an important role
overseeing
intelligence also you know they may go
along in the beginning but man they're
going to pound
the agency and its officers if something
goes wrong
the importance to the intelligence
community community of the church
hearings of the 1970s and of 9 11.
so the church
hearings
really set the basic
limits that they they we didn't have
intelligence committees doing regular
oversight before those hearings uh they
exposed the secrets that the cia had
sought
hardest to protect the crown jewels they
were known as back then
and they they became a public and the
public was shocked by some of what it
discovered as i look back to be honest
um
it's amazing
how little of the really
nasty stuff
cia did back in in those days i mean
there were occasional assassination
uh plots but you know you can list them
on one hand
and mostly they were unsuccessful
people would
you know come up with crazy ideas but
but generally they weren't carried out
today we live in a world where
the agency but also our special
operations commands routinely
engage in targeted killing of our
adversaries we've gone from a world
where that simply wasn't
done
uh to a world in which it's it's it's
it's
you know at least considered practically
every every day of the week
so the church committee
established rules established oversight
you know set a new framework and we now
live in that and i think that framework
is is better for all concern than what
came before 9 11
turned the cia for a time
from an intelligence collecting agency
to essentially a paramilitary covert
action agency
this the cia
had a plan for what to do
after the twin towers went down and
george tenet
if you read the histories was very clear
with president bush you know we're ready
to go
and they were they were on the ground in
afghanistan within a matter of weeks
and they took down the taliban in
afghanistan you know
with brilliant
handfuls of americans
working with their assets in the
northern alliance the tajiks others in
afghanistan
they let osama bin laden slip away our
current secretary of defense jim mattis
pleaded with his colleagues to authorize
greater use of force to prevent
bin laden from slipping through the
mountains into pakistan as one reason
general mattis is is beloved by so many
at the pentagon is he was he was right
about that and everybody remembers but
uh
secretary rumsfeld wouldn't wouldn't
sign off on it but the 9 11 period
made counter terrorism
the the center of the cia's mission and
made increasingly use of drones
you know this high-tech
way of
taking people out
the the instrument of choice and so the
ci began running a drone program that
consumed resources
targeting
executing these missions
after 9 11 the cia
told by the president of the white house
uh the nation is a threat there's a
threat of use of biological weapons
chemical weapons you know our whole
population could be at risk
you need to know you need to find out
what they're going to do to us ci
crossed a line that i think in
retrospect we all feel was a mistake to
have crossed
in terms of how it interrogated people
and i've been vast discussion of that i
won't go through the details but it does
shock the conscience to read what our
intelligence officers
did
in those in those interrogate
interrogation programs
and
i think there is nobody at the cia who'd
like to get back into that business
nobody
uh
i think it was it was it led to such
public uh criticism
the csci in the end depends on on trust
of the of the of the public uh
you know when we when we see our
soldiers the ball game
you know everybody claps we we love our
military
the cia officers take similar risks but
they don't get applause quite the
opposite they they usually get
pretty sharp criticism and i think they
don't they don't like that and they'd
like to have a some better base of
support so that it's one reason that
they they would be so worried about
about being asked to go into the
interrogation business again big time
they don't want to do it
uh i think that this is an agency that
would like to go back to its basic
mission of collecting intelligence and
do less
of the secret ward you know uh
counterterrorism
uh
and all the related missions that i
think that people feel the years after 9
11 while it was essential for the
country in terms of protecting the
country that the cia act
that in terms of the agency it's morale
it's it's basic mission
that was not a good period well ten
years ago body of lies came out and in
that book you write
that quote this was the real card
america had in the intelligence game not
its money certainly not its human
intelligence but its ability to overhear
almost every conversation or any
conversation in the world
the fusion of our
surveillance resources the nsa's big
ears in the sky our ability to
get into the
fiber optic communications cables that
carry
every internet message every phone call
these days
that is a weapon that no other country
has and i that's it's obviously been
very powerful if you look
you don't have to go all the way back to
911 just look at the campaign against
isis americans haven't paid much notice
but
the islamic state arose in
swept
across iraq and syria in 2014
three years later it was obliterated
it has almost no territory tens of
thousands of its people have been killed
and
that has been not had been much written
about it but that's been a war that our
special operations
command
powered by this same information every
time you have any digital ping
that says somebody who's threatened an
american threatened to bread threatened
a french person
you know is
electronically visible it's likely that
that person's soon going to be a target
so this has been a much more ruthless
and effective campaign than people
realize
and it's
you know
i think
much more journalism needs to be done
about about how
this was conducted what the human costs
were
uh
just the the scenario where i think
there has not been enough reporting and
should be more
julian assange
edward snowden how are they viewed in
the intel community
well to quote
mike pompeo the ci director
he's described wikileaks as a hostile
intelligence service
i think edward snowden who resides in
moscow under the protection of the
russian government is
is seen
as someone who has
turned over some of america's most
sensitive secrets uh in a way that they
can be used by by russia
and china whether that was his intention
or not um
so i think
there's a pretty hard-nosed view
among intelligence
professionals about about both
certainly
when there's been a suggestion that
there might be
some sort of plea bargain for edward
snowden
my sense is that people in the
intelligence community have
loudly said they want to be
sure that this is not any easy
negotiation that he had that he he'd be
required to explain precisely what he
did
and and that it
his
simple answer is there's not a lot of
sympathy for them
who are the huffmans
so in every one of my novels that's a
great question in every one of my novels
there is a character named hoffman
uh in my first novel frank hoffman was
the baywood station chief and he was the
foil against whom the hero of the book
tom rogers who was
modeled after the real life
robert ames
plays off
and uh
hoffman was just an outrageous
foul-mouthed you know cranky you know uh
funny guy uh
kind of person we meet in real life
and i just i i found the character so
uh engaging that i just kept having him
or a member of his family his son his
cousin
in every book there's somebody somebody
named hoffman i don't
a lot of
uh spy novels have the same protagonist
in every every book as we know i mean
harry bosch and michael connolly novels
is the detective novelist version i just
never wanted to do that i i like to
start fresh with each book
with a new set of characters new set of
uh issues that that interests me i hate
repeating myself
but i did
decide that i'd keep this
continuity through through the hoffman
family
and there's a hoffman in in in this book
um
by uh
although she isn't immediately obvious
yeah and i again i i hope people when
they look at my work over 30 years will
see maybe in these in these hoffman
characters see the arc
of the ci's experience the ways it's
changed the ways it's it's it's the same
uh i'd i'd love people to someday be
able to look at this body at work and
say you know here's in fiction
but a
fairly realistic fiction a chronicle of
the life and times of our intelligence
agency
and what what changed what didn't what
worked and what didn't
again
in every book
one basic theme is we don't know enough
to be doing the things that we're doing
another way to interpret the hoffman
legacy throughout your books is
the cia's a little high bound maybe a
little parochial
the hoffmans are always
acting at the margins uh they're they're
loudmouth show-offs
uh uh
they're you know schemers and
manipulators they're often the people
who say
this you know this
ci bureaucracy is ridiculous and we're
going to do things through the back door
because the front door is you know
it's not going to work so yes they're
they're they're iconoclasts
speaking of the bureaucracy that's
another theme in your books is the
difficulty or the politics
of negotiating the intelligence
community
bureaucracy
i i i think that's absolutely right the
the bureaucracy gets thicker and
and more viscous
uh in in each in each book um
once upon a time you know in my first
novel
um
frank hoffman the baywood station chief
could just order something and it would
happen and he would cross the line he
didn't care
that was true
interestingly about the real life
operations on which on which that novel
was based the case officer crossed a lot
of lines thinking he was doing the right
thing
as the legal controls congressional
oversight have increased so has the
bureaucracy the ci's just been through
uh
top to bottom
bureaucratic reorganization which which
made the the org chart even more
confusing than it was before it was
taken i'm not sure it's been entirely
digested
so
the people spent an awful lot of time
going to meetings they spent an awful
lot of time covering their backsides
writing memos
to to this one on that one
it's in that sense
uh
it's sort of the opposite of uh what you
think of
in a james bond novel where you know
this super cool guy in a tuxedo just
goes out with his gun and shoes people
you know he james bond would spend an
awful lot of time writing memos for the
file
in the real world
so what is the cooperation level between
mi5 mi6 the cia the nsa the dia
cooperation with
foreign intelligence services liaison
partners as the cia likes to call them
is
and has been
since the beginning uh
excellent it's really the ci's biggest
asset is that
because it's really the only
powerful
global source of information with all
these technical resources to feed its
its uh collection and analysis
able to share things with partners uh
that that they couldn't get anywhere
else so
you know i every day uh some
leader of some foreign intelligence
service comes to langley to visit
top officials of the ci talk share
information and that
extends to people you wouldn't think
russians chinese there's a lot more
intelligence sharing about issues of
common interest than
people like to like to say publicly so i
think that's a
big asset the fact that
the u.s has a lot of friends around the
world and they still respect the agency
as a source of information
in terms of internal sharing you asked
about our own our domestic agencies well
you know there's still an awful lot of
silos out there
we have 17 different intelligence
agencies each of them wants to have its
own analysts who are doing the analysis
the idea that you you know merge
if this is a company and you had 17
different
sets of accountants you know going over
this essentially the same paperwork
you'd say that's nuts that would
wouldn't last
five minutes in the in the business
world a lot of it continues
uh in in the intelligence world there's
been an effort to remove the pipes but
everybody insists my information's so
sensitive my sources if i can't and
nobody can know about them so it's all
controlled by the by the originators as
the their
buzzword goes and
even now
after
more than a decade of talking about
breaking down the stovepipes they're
still there
so
dan coats's job is to
kosa's job is to oversee this
sprawling intelligence community and i'd
say one
problem is that it's too big i think
this ci is too big i i think
um
this is a situation where less would be
more where we're a smaller
uh more genuinely clandestine
intelligence service that went after the
targets that really matter or life and
death for the
u.s uh would be would be would be better
i just i just think that the sprawl and
i i'm not even
including the consultants who multiplied
by the tens of thousands
uh it's it's just it's vast and it feeds
a
information system that nobody could
digest we generate far more
information than any anybody could could
analyze maybe machines computers will be
able to do the analysis for us i i i
hope so but
over time i guess that's one other
observation that i that i'd make this
this just too darn big
uh we we
we spend plenty of money
but uh
you know sometimes we're just we're just
lucky that we managed to to distinguish
the signal the thing that really matters
from all the noise that's around it
202 is the area code 748 8200 if you
live in the east and central time zones
202-748-8201 for those of you in the
mountain and pacific time zones this is
the first of our 12 special fiction
editions of in-depth in 2018 and we're
pleased that david ignatius columnist
for the washington post and the author
of 10
best-selling thrillers is our guest
we've talked for an hour now it's your
turn let's begin with david in tulsa
oklahoma hi david you're on the air hi
thank you for taking my call
in october november i had some students
from one of my u.s history classes
attend a talk at the university of tulsa
of two survivors of the atomic bombs in
hiroshima and nagasaki
and it heightened the paranoia that my
students have as to how many countries
have access to nuclear weapons
and how dangerous is our world today
particularly with the dialogue
that we hear constantly
uh on twitter or uh on the news
and i would like to hear our
guests answer to that
thank you david
i think the danger of nuclear weapons is
as great as it was when i was a boy when
we used to
literally have
airaid drills and think about fallout
shelters and there was a general
national paranoia about nuclear war that
receded with the end of the cold war
but
there's no question that we live in a
world where the danger of accidents
leading to a nuclear exchange whether
it's between the u.s and north korea
which we're all thinking about now the
idea of having
boasts and taunts about nuclear war
being exchanged by an american president
and a foreign leader i find deeply
disturbing
um and the the danger of a war between
an india and a pakistan or or
you know name your other set of nuclear
armed armed countries is just it's just
too large
one thing that we hear again and again
from
former national security advisers is
about
moments when they were told
because of mistakes that missiles were
on the way
and they had a couple of minutes to
decide whether to launch our own
missiles in retaliation
the point is this is an area where the
danger of miscalculation
leading to catastrophic
outcomes is so large
nobody should joke about um
or
use this as an area where they taught
that my button is bigger than your
button stuff
it just i think americans should
share the view that's not appropriate
these weapons are too dangerous
well david ignatius in your paper this
morning on the front page is a story
about how the u.s
miscalculated north korea's abilities
when you read a story given your
background like that
how do you read that story
um the first thing that i was struck by
when i when i read the story
is what a hard target north korea is
this is this is a country where it's
more than usually difficult to
get information to recruit agents to
trust what the agents tell you the north
koreans are very good at hiding things
they know when our spy satellites are
overhead they don't
let us see things except intentionally
they do a lot of their research
underground we're not entirely sure
where all the underground facilities are
so
that's not to excuse not understanding
how rapidly their their program moved
it's just to say this was this was the
ultimate hard target
and uh
i think
we would all say okay
so we want our intelligence agency to do
better to be more aggressive we need to
know we need to know where the north
koreans are
when you think about what that involves
about the risks to the people who do
that collection who try in clandestine
ways to get into north korea or recruit
north korean agents inside their nuclear
establishment i mean man think about
that as a challenge but no question that
um we need to know more we're too close
to
uh to conflict with north korea not not
to treat them as absolutely a you know
number one
collection
target but
you need to think about what that's
going to involve
next call for david ignatius comes from
richard in ventura california go ahead
richard
as an enthusiastic follower of book tv
and a reader of david ignatius's novels
i'd like to know more about his father's
career in the cia and what writers he
enjoys reading in the same worlds of
spy novels or politics because he's
often on tv
and i certainly if i can say so i
certainly agree with his comments about
kai bird's the goods thigh it's a great
read
and
and he's also his biography that
crossing mammal bomb gate his
autobiography
because i grew up in the middle east in
the 1950s they were very memorable to me
richard why were you living in the
middle east in the 1950s
aramco my father worked for ramco in
saudi arabia
and in what kind of position
he was a personnel manager in in
rostoner and dahran thank you sir
so the first thing i need to
make clear
before my dad calls on the other line
my father never worked for the for the
cia my dad worked for the
pentagon he served in the navy
in world war ii on an aircraft carrier
he was in many of the
naval engagements in world war ii
and
he came to work for president kennedy in
1961
initially as assistant secretary of the
army and then under secretary of the
army then assistant secretary of defense
finally was secretary of the navy
for almost two years
so he had a distinguished career uh in
government
but it was it was never in in this in
the cia
given his background his military
background did that influence
your life choices and have you been
approached were you ever recruited
the
second question first no i was i was
never never recruited
in terms of my life choices i grew up in
the 1960s
and i felt as a young man
strongly that the vietnam war was a
mistake was wrong and led to some tough
uh
conversations between uh me and my dad
which was part of my part of my growing
up
and
when i got out of college
what i wanted to do with a passion was
be a journalist i'd been
writing for my
high school newspaper
since i was 12
13.
i used to
go
cover concerts and pretend i was i'd say
i was reporting for my high school
newspaper and be backstage at the
temptations or the
junior walker and the all-stars at the
howard theater so i you know i had a i
had a i had a passion for for
uh
for that work um
my first job as a reporter was
for the wall street journal the wall
street journal sent me
gone to harvard i'd been a graduate
student at cambridge in england
and the wall street journal asked me to
go cover the steel workers union
in pittsburgh
and if there was a more unlikely person
in america to cover the steel workers
i'd like to know who was but
i threw myself into it and i learned how
to talk to
people in that union and make them as
sources and break stories and i just i
just loved it i fell in love with with
the work
uh in later years of my career certainly
when i covered the middle east and then
um
after 9 11 i have often
gone to war zones and
covered these wars
uh as an an embedded journalist i
this year was in syria in july with our
special forces for
spent three days there i've been in
syria a couple times earlier in this war
i've been often off and off into to iraq
a couple dozen times
so i ended up
wanting to have a window as a journalist
on what our military does
there are times when i wonder
looking back if i should have
served my country in some direct way i
hope as a journalist the work that i do
serves the country in its own way but
it's not the same as as working for the
government and i i look back now uh you
think well you know should i done that
um that's you know one of the things you
think about as you get older what are
the choices you made and how does it all
add up
some of the references in your books
include references to voa radio sawa et
cetera
rfe
are they propaganda services and are
they effective
well voa i wouldn't describe as a
propaganda service voa
wants to be a source of objective news
much as the bbc is
for for
britain
and i think the voa has has some
excellent journalists
it's now run by
a colleague and friend amanda bennett
who's journalism i respect a lot she's
edited
philadelphia inquirer and
portland oregonian and other other
papers
radio sawa was more specifically set up
as a
source of pro-american information
during the
years of conflict in the middle east it
had that as its mission
would you call it propaganda you know i
i'm sure there's some good journalists
there who'd be offended by it but
there's no question that its mission was
quite specifically to push an american
line
next call for david ignatius is hugh in
ashland virginia hugh thanks for holding
please go ahead with your question or
comment
i just want to say first of all thank
you so much for the openness in this
discussion this is what
people need to hear so that we can unite
and bring this country back on track i
just want to
ask mr ignatius bringing him back to his
wall street journal days
give him two names to comment on and
also to comment on the importance and
journalism that facts certainly do
matter i was interviewed by jonathan
whitney of the wall street journal back
in 1983 it triggered a
the article triggered an investigation
eventually caused the resignation of
jim wright from speaker of the house and
shame and i also had read a book
back then that helped me
uh know what i was how i was being
manipulated the book was authored by
harry rizzitsky a high level cia
operative so i'd love to have his
comments on those points and thank you
again and
we can get this country back on track
you if you would given your references
that you made can you tell us a little
bit about yourself
well if i can't share my name i have no
fear
if you'll let me do that i think it
would be very interesting for your
listeners and i would like to bring it
back to your programming so that we can
truly heal america in the right way my
name is
hugh hughh the last name is
charleston t like tom
r-a-u-l-s-e-n like nancy i share common
background with president trump and i
heard mr ignatius mention his father god
bless him if he's still with us and my
mother was a supermodel who posed for
wave recruitment posters as a poster of
her in the national archives in
washington dc
hugh trulson
any
any recognition of that name i i don't
know mr charleston but i sure like what
he what he had to say and i share uh
with a passion his feeling that
uh our country has to become more united
i think our
divisions
are now our greatest national weakness
and our adversaries are exploiting them
uh on the names that you mentioned
jonathan whitney was a great uh
intense uh
sometimes over the top investigative
reporter for the wall street journal
when i worked there he was famous um we
had in those days some great characters
who did investigative reporting
i was kind of
studying their moves there was a guy in
the washington bureau who was one of my
mentors named jerry landauer
who was just a great character broke
some some big stories in that period
harry rozzitski is a famous
uh figure in the intelligence world and
intelligence history i did not ever
meet him to my knowledge so i can't
comment on that and and
mr charleston
mentioned my dad my dad is 97
my mom is 92
they're both
thank goodness
in good health i'll see them both
later today
go for a visit
i just mentioned uh because i talked
about my dad's career serving uh the
our government
the the u.s navy
launched a guided missile destroyer
this spring named after my father the
uss paul ignatius
so in our family we when we say paul
ignatius you're talking about the man or
the ship
so that's a great big warship it'll be
at sea for 30 years and is a wonderful
memorial to my dad who i think everybody
who knows
my dad knows what a special person he is
there is an armenian
connection in one of your books
and does that uh reflect on your
heritage it does there's an armenian
connection in my life my grandfather uh
hofstep was born in
what was then the ottoman empire uh in
an armenian town in eastern turkey
he made his way to america
as did the woman he married she came by
way of manchester england
in my living room
we have the piano that my grandmother
alisa
brought to america from manchester
england it's an old beckstein piano
i opened the piano bench and saw some of
the music that she'd brought with her
and that piano
is
played
sometimes by my own daughter who's now a
doctor
whose name is elisa so she sits at that
piano where her great-grandmother
said
my armenian background is something that
i'm i'm proud of
i've tried to
travel to armenia and get to know people
there and and support
humanitarian causes in armenia
um uh
the miracle of our country is that we're
all from somewhere and we are americans
first but we you know get to know and
feel
uh comfortable with explore our
ethnic roots in in my case that's
involved getting to know more about the
armenians their story of their suffering
and the genocide
in 1915 and and the whole of the story
of this people
well if you are interested in hugh
charlson our previous caller
viewers are sending in emails with links
to some of the information about him and
we're going to move on to thomas in
humboldt texas thomas you're on with
author david ignatius
how are you doing dave
good uh yeah listen uh remember that
submarine a russian submarine captain
who refused to launch and i believe he
saved the whole world if you ever
remember his name let me know
but uh i was talking about the policies
that reagan used against russia that
made him spend you know trillions
on military spending i think china's
kind of using it on us now you know our
health care
mess
we elected the president on the you know
premise that you know make america great
again but uh it seemed like we're making
it broke you know what i'm saying
and one more thing the uh refugees from
south america
explain what happened in the 80s thank
you so
much um
so um
let me take the the last of those uh
first um i think when you're talking
about refugees you mean
uh refugees from central america at the
time that the cia was running a a
pro covert action program against
nicaragua there were refugees who were
involved in that maybe you mean the
cuban refugees were part of the
pigs invasion
all of those groups i think pretty much
have have assimilated into into american
life there's not much not much of a
vestige left except occasionally
politically
your point about about china
pushing us into an arms race
that's going to bankrupt america is a
powerful one
that the chinese
do pose
uh an increasing
threat i think um
an increasing ability to interfere with
the united states
but the way in which we should respond
to that i think is is complicated one
thing that bothers me is that we
continue to spend
massive amounts
on all the traditional arsenal of
weapons that we've had the aircraft
carriers the bomber wings air bases
everywhere
all this traditional power which
increasingly in the age of cyber warfare
is is
is vulnerable
and so we're spending the hundreds of
billions
for legacy systems and maybe not
spending the money that we need to do
to spend for the systems that will
actually
combat our adversaries in the in the
future the future war will not be waged
by tanks and aircraft carriers it'll be
waged in space initially it'll be waged
electronically it's just not going to
look like any war that we've seen i
suspect
so i i share your view that we need to
be a lot more
smart in looking at this budget america
you know we don't have enough money to
spend on every every every weapon system
under the sun the pentagon traditionally
is terrible at making these choices
everybody wants everything you know and
the navy
wants its own version the air force
its own different version
senator mccain somebody i respect a lot
sent a letter to secretary of defense
jim mattis a couple months ago which she
basically said as we know senator mccann
is very ill now but he said
you need to make choices
mr secretary you need to make choices
about what we can acquire and what we
can't
you need to make strategic choices
because we can't afford everything and i
think senator mccain was absolutely
right as
as is the caller
in 2011 blood money came out sophie marx
is the protagonist
it's about pakistan
this is a tweet from president trump in
the past couple of weeks
the u.s has foolishly given pakistan
more than 33 billion dollars in aid over
the past 15 years and they have given us
nothing but lies and deceits
to say that they've given us nothing but
lies and deceit is wrong and i've seen
the evidence that that's wrong i've
traveled with the pakistani military
in the swan valley in the north of
pakistan which was once infested by the
taliban
and i've been with their military as
they as they move to clear that that
territory at considerable loss of
pakistani life i've traveled
to
south waziristan which is where al qaeda
hid out
and i've seen the joint operations the
u.s ran with the pakistani military to
go after those those al-qaeda cells one
by one by one and again i i know that
the pakistanis paid a price in lives
lost that said um it's also true as
president trump tweeted it's just it's
just ask anybody in our military who's
served out there um the pakistanis have
not played straight up with the united
states they have continued to maintain a
relationship with the haqqani network as
it's called which operates in
in afghanistan is one of the most deadly
uh groups in afghanistan is directly
responsible for for killing americans
the u.s keeps pressuring the pakistanis
to if you say you're we're fighting the
same adversary
let's go after the haqqani network and
the pakistanis have refused
um you know i think it's usually a
mistake
in foreign policy to force things to
extremes
you know that's why foreign policy by
tweet isn't a good idea in 140 or 280
characters you can't really do justice
to the nuance of the relationship the
united states needs to have with
pakistan it's going to be complicated
but the basic point are the pakistanis
being fully open with us
about about what they do no they're not
do we have a right to protest their
continuing relationship with a group
that's killing americans would kill
americans right now today if they could
yes we do so i i s somewhere between
you know this crazy tweet let's let's
throw the buggers overboard and and uh
and you know this
this current situation is is good policy
i you know the pakistan is going to
continue to be important in the united
states it's a nuclear power
maintaining a dialogue with a country
that has nuclear weapons and and says
it's prepared to use them against india
really important you don't just walk
away from that relationship well from
that book blood money here's general
malik director of the isi
these americans are the clowns of the
world are they not my brother they drop
their bombs from the sky and when we get
angry they think of friendship they
think they can make war and then charm
us with money really they bring birth on
a summer day
wow
that's a good argument for cutting off
money isn't it
general malik is uh is
the head of the
pakistani intelligence service in my
novel
uh that uh novel was was well researched
readers of my column know that i i
interviewed the head of
pakistani intelligence
general
ahmed suja pasha
several times so when i
describe offices and dialogue there's a
little
check mark next to it um
the
the pakistanis have driven a generation
of american military and intelligence
officers nuts
um by by by
not fully sharing their relationships
with some of these groups and the
pakistanis
protest
understandably i guess
we're in the business of collecting
information to protect ourselves
the haqqani network which you want us to
just never talk to again
we get valuable intelligence from them
it it helps us and maybe it helps you
too
so don't tell us never to talk to them
um
again pakistan is a is a for if you're
if you're a spy novelist uh it is some
of the richest terrain imaginable
cruising around
uh peshawar uh is is just it's a scene
that you couldn't conjure up any any
anywhere else if you
love the
novels of
19th century britain uh
the kyber pass the grand trunk road uh
there's a lot of that is is still alive
and you can you know as a journalist or
novelist go see it
where did the name sophie marks your
protagonist come from in blood money
well she uh what should we get into that
in that in that in that book as you
remember she she has another name
because she's nervous about about the
about the name of marx
i always have terrible trouble picking
characters names i'll make lists
you know match this first name with that
last name and
sometimes the character's
name will change after the second draft
because i just hate the name so much
there is a computer programmer that you
can get that is a name generator for
writers so you can come up with names of
course you know once you come up with a
name you have to check to make sure
there's no real person that could in any
way be confused with this fictional
character um so
that's uh
but uh sophie marks you know i honestly
i i sure i just
she emerged as a as a as a character's
name uh after you know i'd made a list
of of you know
150 other ones that i chucked out
am i reading too much into names
or do these really create angst
so you want a character's name that um
will uh be consistent with with what the
character how the character behaves
uh
i i've always thought the
best uh signer of names to his
characters uh was charles dickens you
know who who has um you know the the
blacksmith and great expectations joe
gargery
uh the uh the kind of impudent uh
spendthrift
uh
always you know says something will turn
up wilkins micawber you know we say
macabre and we instantly think think of
that of that character dickens um just
uh you know had a flare for these
unforgettable names
um
you know it's it's uh
often your your your characters uh
change in the course of writing a novel
as you as you learn more about a
character
as the character does things on the page
the name that you initially thought was
appropriate changes
the name of of the
ci head of operations in my new novel
the quantum spy john vandal
i changed uh on the final draft it was
something entirely different and i
realized the name that i had
and certain details just didn't fit who
this person had become
so you know it's the fun thing about
about a novel is um you get to control
every every detail if you decide you can
give somebody a different name bing
it's a different thing have you ever
surprised yourself
with changing a character and maybe a
character becomes
a good guy bad guy etc
characters uh
can sort of take things over uh that
they just
that they they do outrageous things
they're they're cleverer than you
thought they were
they just end up taking
more space and becoming more important
to the story and that's happened to me
often
the
some of my
middle east or pakistani intelligence
officers end up being a lot more
complicated and and devious and
interesting so they just you know i
decided a smaller role and
make it larger
we were talking about blood money a
moment ago that that novel opens with
something that
i'm proud of as a writer
because it takes readers to a place that
we need to go that's
hard to go
and it imagines what it would be like to
be under
a ci drone attack
in the tribal areas of pakistan
i traveled to the tribal areas to see
what that space looked like i traveled
in a one-engine plane with a pakistani
officer
bumping over the mountains bumping over
the badlands where the only people
underneath us were al-qaeda and their
supporters i asked him at one point what
would happen if we had engine trouble
and he turned to me and said
sir we would die
not complicated
so
i was able to to describe what
it would feel like to hear
that hum
at 10 000 feet
above you and see the
gleam on the body of this drone
and
begin to run in terror
from the place that you thought might be
hit and
then the loss of everybody around you
who who was not able to escape
and
that's happened over and over again i
understand that drones are are
supposed to be more precise and
targeting than any other kind of weapon
system i i get that
but the drone is a terrifying weapon and
i i felt if i could take readers
make you feel what it would be like to
be on the ground and as i said hear that
hear that
were in your ear
see the little flashing light and then
panic that would you'd be better
something we need to think what would
that be like because we're doing that as
i said we in this period we've been
doing that every day
let's hear from margaret in san antonio
hi margaret
hi and thank you c-span for bringing
fiction to authors this is a great
addition and i'm enjoying this today
my question is do any of your books have
the mossad
in it
and why do you ask that question
margaret
because i love uh gabriel alon the books
uh by daniel silva and and i love
reading about israel
thank you ma'am
so the the answer is is yes i i also
like dan silva's
books
in the my first novel agents of
innocence uh where there is this moral
um
nightmare
for for readers and and for the
cia officers at the time where the us is
working with the head of palestinian
intelligence there are some
very sympathetic israeli uh intelligence
characters who were who were struggling
to learn what the americans are doing or
worried about it or trying to figure out
how to approach the americans
israelis have have made
appearances in other books of mine
since then
i felt since there are so many good
authors who really focus on the mossad
and there's just a lot of literature
that comes out about it
dan silva's books are one example but
there are many that um
it would be good to write about things
that were less written about so i i
haven't
attended to make them a primary subject
but they often
their operatives are woven through a
bunch of my stories and i would note
that we have invited mr silva on to be
on this series and we're holding out
hope that he'll be here in the fall good
now if you can't get through on the
phone lines and want to participate in
our conversation today you can do it via
social media as well at book tv is our
twitter handle it's also our instagram
address
and it will connect you on facebook as
well and our email is booktv at
cspan.org
sam lewisville texas you are on the air
with david ignatius
sam you with us
yes yes please go ahead we're listening
um
mr ignatius uh i appreciate everything
you've written and i look forward uh to
the incredible work you you have in your
future
uh the comment i'd like to make is what
you mentioned earlier about the good spy
robert ames incredible hero
unsung hero of of the war on terror
but what what impressed me
in the book that i didn't really
anticipate that he wasn't alone that his
wife and his children and they too
were serving their country
in in situations that were very harsh
very very
difficult and they were equally in
harm's way
and how his how his wife managed the
children and got him educated and
was able to purchase all their clothing
through the sears catalog and different
things like that
and just to comment that
to all those who serve
our country
to be grateful for their
their wives and children that are
they're there with them you know james
bond never had a wife or a family
uh but the people who serve our country
do
and those wives and children are right
there along with their fathers and and i
just appreciate so much the opportunity
to
to bring this
this thought and sentiments to uh
to to our community
thank you very much for taking my call
sam when you say our community are you a
member of the intelligence community
no not really uh just the
community of uh all of us in this
country thank you sir um
david ignatius
i i couldn't possibly possibly say it
better than sam did
the
families of our
foreign service officers because they're
exposed to danger our intelligence
officers overseas
don't get recognition sometimes they
don't fully know what their
spouses are doing
because it's it's so secret
robert m's wife yvonne
was a
very courageous person
deeply shattered by the loss of her of
her husband
i think back to
the mentioned earlier in the show
on the day that robert ames was killed
when that car bomb hit the american
embassy in beirut
i was walked to the
front door of the marine guards the
front door as i say about a half hour
before the bomb hit and i've stayed in
touch ever since with the woman
who was a secretary walk me down there
her name is rebecca won't give her last
name because i don't want to invade her
privacy
but
the
trauma that our people serving overseas
um who are not in the military don't get
don't get the applause of the ball games
but the things that they've lived
through the the the the risks that they
and their family members have taken it's
really worth remembering i mean the next
time you see a foreign service officer
give them a hug i mean it's my basic
feeling and certainly that goes to their
families too
on the flip side
robert hansen alder james
how for so long could they get away
with what they were doing when you look
at
just in reading your books mr ignatius i
i felt paranoid
the first answer is the russians are
good at what they do
they run agents
effectively
they cover their tracks
their their tradecraft is good
uh
hanson
aldrich went to great lengths to
conceal their activities
the people whose names they exposed who
risked their lives for the united states
to provide information ended up getting
killed
and these these were consequential
things that they did
and
the real betrayals
we have been
lucky historically that the number of
people who've been recruited from our
intelligence service
has been
smaller than the
with a lot of other countries look at
britain britain was just riddled with
soviet agents turned out the head of
you know their anti-soviet operations
was really working for the russians
we've had
more cases and i'd note just coming back
to our original
theme of the quantum spy the number of
chinese recruitments
of of their versions of
walter james or
or robert hanson they're moles inside
the intelligence community there are
there are two live cases uh going on
this year there's a some big
investigations underway about their
activities people the chinese have
gotten much more aggressive in going
after us personnel
so uh
you know
those those those cases are are real
they haunt
uh the cia when i first was starting out
as a journalist
um getting interested in writing about
intelligence one of the people i took to
lunch
repeatedly this is in the late 1970s
think how long ago that is
was james jesus angleton
the
legendary head of ci counterintelligence
who had retired but who was still uh
fascinated at the point of obsession
with all these russian cases he was
convinced the russians were you know
almost literally behind every tree
and
and he he i think one reason he was so
paranoid about russian
manipulation
russian intelligence activities was he
had befriended kim philby the british
mi6 officer who was in
washington as their liaison and he had
they'd been pals they'd
launched and dinnered and angleton had
told him everything he knew
and then suddenly angleton had realized
that he had shared these secrets with
somebody who was a stone-cold traitor
and i think he never never was the same
after that i think a new biography on
james angleton came out last year
and book tv covered it if you go to
booktv.org our website you can type in
james angleton and book and you can
watch it online
there this is an email from ken
and ken says i offer you this title for
a future novel the reluctant pessimist
is what he would call it
but he also asks has the world surprised
you in any large way
and ken is writing from catskill new
york
well
i like the reluctant
pessimist
my greatest failing i think as a
as a journalist is that i'm often uh
an optimist i i want to look for the
reasons why something will work
certainly writing about the middle east
um
frederick said when i first began
covering the middle east in 1980 david
pessimism pays
so
maybe i should be the reluctant uh
pessimist
after after all these years
forgive me what was the second half of
that has the world surprised you in any
large way
i was
surprised and pleased by the
unraveling of the
of the soviet union
i was surprised and
deeply
troubled by the inability of u.s
military power
to
create stability in iraq after the u.s
invasion 2003
and by the continuing
difficulty in using our military power
to achieve political ends
and i think it's a there's a real
lesson there
i've been surprised
to be honest by the way in which our
country
politically is is fraying and
fragmenting
we are so much more divided and angry as
a country now than i ever imagined would
be possible there is so much smaller
ground on which reasonable people can
stand and
discuss things and agree on the facts
and then agree on what policies make
sense
uh that surprises me and worries me i
think it's our biggest problem as a
country i think our current political
leadership
the president but also people in the
other in the democratic party really
start with the white house are making
that problem worse every time something
is healing in our national life it seems
like there's a desire to rip the scab
open
and that surprises me and worries me
and tell me if i'm being too general
here but throughout your novels mr
ignatius
the president and the white house
are relatively peripheral
to what you're writing about but it's
all
yeah i'll leave it there the briefest uh
cameos in which somebody will make
reference to the present or go see the
president but
uh i i think it's so easy to write in
stereotypes about about the white house
and the situation room and
and uh
it just takes away from what the the
granularity that interests me the the
the real life
um
you could write different a different
kind of novel about the national
security advisor or you know senior nsc
person
uh who's in the middle of that and then
try to write that as realistically as
possible
not the world of house of cards uh not
not the
somewhat uh you know
stereo stereotypical world but but
something uh that's closer to the way it
really happens
uh maybe in a
in the future i'll write a a novel like
that but uh it's it's partly i just feel
like as soon as i got the president
involved i'm in the world of cliche
it's just it's very hard to write a
president who's he's
either a description of the actual
president or a recent one where it's
somebody who's very fanciful and
just never wanted to do that
a chat in the garden pod tweets into you
which one of your books have been made
into movies
so um
the only book that's been made into a
movie so far
is is body of lies and that was made
into a movie uh starring leonardo
dicaprio and ridley scott
directed assuming ridley scott was
director
mark strong played the chief of
intelligence russell crowe played
uh leonardo dicaprio's boss so that was
a big hollywood movie i think it's a
wonderful
film hbo shows it uh often enough i've
had
other
deals that i thought were going to lead
to movies tom cruise wanted to play the
character in my novel a firing offense
and happily paid a lot of money
for what looked like a project there
were three drafts of a screenplay that
got written but it never got produced so
there are other things
bumping along i'd love to see a project
that is under discussion with a british
television network to do uh my novel the
increment uh about iran and about
secret operations based in britain as a
tv cable tv series we'll see we'll see
if that comes to fruition but uh
yeah the uh takes a long time to for
these hollywood things to happen
what's the process like
either for
um the one that did get made or body of
lies or some of the others that didn't
get does it i'll talk about the one that
did get made because uh that's you know
the easiest to describe um
i had been doing some writing for ridley
scott the director on another project he
had an idea for a movie about a
journalist
in iraq who falls in love with an iraqi
a moment journalist who falls in love
with an iraqi man and i had been writing
the treatments for that so i knew the
director
and
when i finished a draft of body of lies
and body of lies again like all my books
pretty realistic it's drawn from the
real fight against al qaeda how we
really have tried to get people inside
the tent of al-qaeda i finished a draft
and
my agent
sent it
uh ridley scott's
development person and that that person
called me from i think was the sundance
film festival and said
you know
i've been up all night i'm supposed to
go be seeing movies at this festival and
i've just been reading your book it's
great you know we love it and so
very quickly a deal was made
and
it happened that hollywood was in one of
those moments where
because there was an expected
screenwriter's strike
every studio was scrambling to line up
all the stars they could do two movies
in the remaining period before the
strike it was thought
so they managed to line up leonardo
dicaprio to do this and you know once
you had director ridley scott the famous
actor
you don't need anything else
um but then there was question of
getting a script that would that could
be shot and
there was one very prominent
screenwriter who worked on it and then
one
uncredited screenwriter uh very well
known but but this is his name is not on
it who
who who
wrote a a new draft that was superb i
think and
that second screenwriter uh asked
uh would often share dialogue share
questions so i would ended up
being involved in the in the
construction of that although i'm not
not a screenwriter when they got down to
filming it of course i wanted to be on
the set i went to morocco i took one of
my daughters with me to morocco which
they turned into amman jordan and she
got to meet leonardo dicaprio and talked
to leonardo dicaprio so long and his
girlfriend came over and said leo it's
time to go so my daughter still
remembers that um
took another daughter to see a shooting
here in the washington dc area so it was
about all three i have three daughters
all three of my daughters went to the
premiere uh in new york
that was a that was a cool family uh
moment um
the i think what what
uh
novelists need to
uh accept is that is so often
people say well what did you think about
the movie that was made in your book i
like the book better it's like people
flatter authors by saying that they like
the book better
in this case i love the movie uh
genuinely but i think people have to
accept that um
the book that you've written has to be
reimagined by somebody else
it has a life on the page but it's gonna
have to become something different
reimagined in the mind of the
screenwriter and then the director
to have any life
something that's you try too literally
to to almost transcribe something from
one medium into another it doesn't work
it has it has to be redone so of course
it's different i mean people
with some of the things that i loved in
body of lies aren't in aren't in the
movie they just got chucked they didn't
work they weren't in this re-imagining
so i think you just have to give it up
and accept that's the way it is
indeed if that doesn't happen it's not
reimagined it's not going to be any good
what does it mean to be optioned
to be optioned means that they pay you a
small amount of money to have the right
to make the movie if
all the stars are in alignment and then
if they do make the movie a typical
option deal they pay you a whole lot
more so you know when people go around
saying oh yeah they option my book i
mean it's great um you you quickly learn
the chances it's going to get made into
a movie are
you know slim to none so you'll bet on
slim
and the amount of money you initially
take in an option deal
is is usually pretty small sometimes
on rare happy occasions they will buy uh
the
property outright it's not an option to
make it they buy it outright and then
then if there's a bidding war i like to
say
author's two favorite words in the
english language are bidding war if
there's a bidding war and the price goes
up
you know but so ideally if you have two
studios two directors two actors who
both want to make it
you know then you begin to get in the
territory where you can pay off your
kids school tuitions
so that's that's lucrative well david
ignatius's book body of lies has been
made into a movie we're going to show
you that trailer and we're also going to
show you some of his favorite authors
and his influences
our world is a lot simpler to put to an
end than you might think
[Music]
our enemy
has realized
we're gonna target
ed hoffman does not know [ __ ] and he
steals it from the guy on the ground and
that's me
protect you don't even protect
yourselves
what i need you to fully understand is
that these people they do not want to
negotiate
i have one rule
if we are to cooperate with you never
lie to me
you're blown
this is a part of the world where
friendship matters
did you know we're at war and it can
save your life
[Music]
when you're running a side operation
you did what you had to do but i have to
trust everyone i can right now all you
got to do is trust me i will not be
responsible for your safety
six o'clock in the morning saving
civilization honey
[Music]
what does that mean
[Music]
well every month for the past 20 years
one of the nation's top non-fiction
authors has joined us on our in-depth
program for a fascinating three-hour
conversation about their work
now just for 2018 in-depth is changing
course we've invited 12 fiction authors
onto our set
authors of historical fiction national
security thrillers science writers
social commentators like coulson
whitehead and brad thor brad meltzer
corey doctorow geraldine brooks and many
others their books have been read by
millions around the country and around
the world
so if you are a reader plan to join us
for in-depth on book tv it's an
interactive program the first sunday of
every month that lets you call in and
talk directly to your favorite authors
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
david ignatius your character in the
quantum spy harris chang is reading the
palacer novels and you list that as one
of your favorites what is that the
palacer novels are a series of six
novels by anthony trollope
that recount the story of the palliser
family
plantagenet palace or as the sign of the
family becomes finally the duke of
omnium by the end of the series
and the reason that i love the books and
that a character in the quantum spy
urges
hear us to read the books is they're
probably the best
political novels that i've ever read
they take over
a long stretch of time in 19th century
england ambitious people charming people
scheming people who are making their way
through london that's not all that
different from the washington that we
know
and
we see the rise and fall of their
ambition and their fortunes
um one of my favorite characters in
the palace or novels is
actually not a members member of
palzer's family
his name is phineas finn
and he's an irish reformed politician a
charmer
handsome
he keeps falling in love with the wrong
women
but these are our books
i find that
19th century novels to which i'm
basically addicted
are
just a wonderful guide for storytellers
like me who want to
learn how to unpack characters and story
but also there are incredible guides to
life if you want to understand what good
behavior is what bad behavior is what
uh
relations between men and women are
really like
the complexity of
of how we behave in the world the
mistakes we make
there's nothing quite like these these
books and i any any reader any any any
reader watcher of book tv who doesn't
know trollops novels should just give
give a try so if we describe somebody as
a troll up what are we what are we
saying about them well trop is famous
for his
industrial uh
practices as a writer trump would get up
every morning and he would write for
two plus hours he'd write a certain
number of words and then that was it
then he'd go off to his job he worked at
the post office
uh the inventor of the famous uh red
letter boxes that we see all over
britain it's said to be was anthony
trump
so he had this life as a bureaucrat and
then another life as a novelist
trollope
put on airs a little bit he loved to go
fox hunting
he all the country the pleasures of the
country gentlemen he wasn't a weren't a
quite so
high and proper himself
he was fascinated uh by um
i mentioned earlier men and women
in almost every tropic novel there
there's a
theme of
someone being jilted
the jilt was the name of one of his one
of his novels
and he regarded that as just the most
outrageous thing where somebody's led on
typically you know a beautiful pure
young woman is led on to believe that so
and so sir so-and-so is going to marry
her and then she's jilted and
it sounds corny
not not for everybody but books that i
love
what's it like to write
a sex scene for one of your novels
are you comfortable doing that um what i
what i've
learned about writing about about sex is
that less is more
that uh
it's the it's the
subtle evocations of of mood contact
it's what surrounds
uh
sex that that's more interesting to to
to read um
also less embarrassing to write
you know i think um
in my earlier books i was trying to be
more commercial and and so
probably went
violated the rule i just just
set forth
uh but um you know my most recent novel
quantum spy there's there's very little
sex
um
uh but there's
i hope there's a richness of
characterization men and women i think
um one of the things i've learned to do
as a writer is to write women characters
in a way that's that's believable and
i'm always happy when women say to me i
love that such as this character
in my first novel there's a scene
with two women in a restaurant
talking about sex and talking about
about men in the world of beirut in
which they live
and many women have said to me that that
scene is their is their favorite uh in
the book and
you know how did you know that's
actually how women talk about sex so
um
you know
one of the many small challenges of
being a novelist
202 is the area code 748 8200 if you
live in the east and central time zone
748-8201 for those of you in the
mountain and pacific time zones plus
we'll cycle through our social media
addresses if you want to participate in
our conversation with novelist and
washington post columnist david ignatius
i want to read a description of one of
your books this is ciro which came out
in 1991 am i saying that correctly yes
ciro yes not cyro
and this was
i don't think you wrote this but i just
want to see what you think about this
this is the description
in the book jacket
made restless by the tightening
restrictions of cia bureaucracy agent
alan taylor oversteps moral and legal
bounds in a top-secret mission to
destabilize the soviet union his new
recruit the beautiful anna barnes who
struggles with complex feelings for
taylor receives a deeper education than
she signed up for in david ignatius's
trademark world of shifting
international and domestic pressures
hidden loyalties and secret agendas
so that book was really fun uh it was my
second novel i had some success with
agents of innocence and i i wanted um
to as i said i also wanted a new
challenge so i got interested in the
story of how
in the later cold war years
the cia had played on the russian
nationalities along the southern edge of
the soviet union the georgians the
chechens the english
the uzbeks
the armenians all along that that
periphery
and i also wanted to
think about right about the experience
of a woman case officer
because i i had been told that the big
problem for women
in
actually
doing operations was
that
when a woman
befriends a man from another culture
says
let's let's go take a walk or just come
come let's have a drink together and you
know
begins the process that leads to
recruitment
men often just see that in in sexual
terms i think this woman's coming on to
me this is about sex
and it puts women in a very
delicate dangerous position i
interviewed a number of women who'd been
senior operations officers and began to
think about that so i created this
character anna anna barnes
who embodies all those dilemmas
and
she and alan taylor who is who is
thinking about this play to kind of
begin to rip at the fabric of
of the soviet union
get involved more and more deeply in a
in a you know what turns out to be a
hideously complicated
set of problems
here again
i was working from
real life
the people i went to see i thank at the
end of the book a man named rusi nassar
who was an uzbek
who after the war ended he had been
recruited by the germans during the war
but after the war ended was in a dp camp
and was picked up first by british
intelligence then by the cia and
had an incredible a fabled career
thinking about uzbekistan thinking about
that whole part of the world he's
incredibly generous in sharing
his insights with me he's passed away
now
imagine and i traveled to uzbekistan
traveled all these places
the the
pleasure of learning a piece of history
i don't think in non-fiction to this day
that this history has really been
adequately
written but it's there just waiting for
somebody to to do the research and uh
you know
what do you think of that description of
your book though
i think it's i think it's i think it's
it's great it's kind of corny uh it's it
sounds like book jacket uh
copy
um but uh you know if it got people to
to pick up the book uh buy the book read
the book
great
the
in this marketplace the question of how
you how you draw a reader into
engagement with your book it's not so
easy i mean a lot of people
are are brand name uh buyers of fiction
i like michael connolly i know that if i
buy a michael connie novel it's going to
be you know the basics the thing that he
knows how to do he's going to have harry
bosch or the lincoln lawyer
character and he's got a new woman
detective and and their their
procedurals he's going to get all the
procedure right i mean i i've never
visited the lapd but i feel like i know
it intimately from all those all those
books so you know i'm going to buy
michael connolly's next book i hope
somebody who
likes realistic novels about the cia has
read 10 of my books so when my next one
comes out
person will say ah you know i know david
aviation but i'll let's i'll give that
give that one a shot so you build up
some brand
equity and you need to be careful not to
write a really dreadful book because you
know
you'll blow that i think it's harder to
break into that that world from outside
i know many former intelligence officers
who dreamed you know when i got out i'm
going to be a spy novelist and there are
enough examples of people who were
intelligence officers starting with
graham greene john lecre
charles mccary
american jason matthews a wonderful new
american novelist who served as
intelligence officers and then you know
found a way to to to write good
commercial books but for each one who's
succeeded i'll bet you there are a dozen
who've tried i've read some of their
books and you know they weren't they
just weren't good novels they're the
people had all the same richness of
experience but they didn't have the
ability to translate it into something
that actually makes you want to stay up
late that's what i always think about
when i write a book
what is it you know that makes you stay
up you know you need to go to bed
you finish one chapter what is it that
makes you read the next chapter even
though you shouldn't what's the thing
that's that's hooking you and then try
to recreate that for for the reader
you also list graham greens the quiet
american is one of your favorite books
i think graham greene who was a british
intelligence officer
is
probably my favorite 20th century
novelist in general
also my favorite spy novelist his novels
are so good to call them spy novels
implies their genre books and they're
much more complicated than that the
quiet american written in vietnam in the
1950s anticipates almost everything that
ends up being
so poisonous and difficult for the
united states when we really go to war
there in the 60s the misplaced idealism
the kind of fatuous belief that we could
uh alter the society that there's a
character who who was the narrator uh
who's a journalist is
kind of obsessively thinking about name
named pyle who's in the american embassy
some kind of attache
is forever spouting off about
some theorist of
of the cold war the name york harding
who's you know gonna found the third way
we're gonna use the third way we're
gonna defeat the communists it's just
it's just um
the perfect and and really terrifying
introduction to our nightmare in vietnam
a decade later well let's hear from
barbara and oak bluffs massachusetts
barbara you've been very patient you're
on with author david ignatius
great great privilege um i am a very
interesting person i'm 70 years old and
my father
was in the oss in london in world war ii
and as many americans know the army
developed the iq test with the army
recruits and apparently my father
joseph gould scored very high on the iq
test and they put him in london in the
oss and for those who don't know the oss
was the precursor to the cia oss
standing for
office of strategic services so my
father joseph gold worked under
bill donovan and arthur goldberger um
who became the supreme court justice
and he did this incredibly creative
thing he
recruited german expatriate communists
who had fled hitler into london
and my father was able to find them
through a bookstore owner books books
and he recruited them into something
that became known as the tool mission he
he he and they were germans remember so
they spoke germany and he
uh put them in planes in german uh army
costumes and gave them you know the
first walkie-talkies and and airdropped
them into germany and they radioed
information back and i'm 70. my
brother's 69 and my brother jonathan has
become a historian of these tool
missions of what my father did and i
called him because when david was
talking about his father
part of the greatest generation and now
we're in our 70s where the boomer
generation
here we have this two generation
relationship to this history
then my brother wrote an article about
this for the unclassified cia journal so
it would be great for people to know
that there's a journal of unclassified
stories his name is jonathan gould as i
said a couple years ago and he's also
written a treatment a movie treatment
and a you know a mini series about this
trying to get it produced it was really
great to hear about david's trials and
tribulations with doing that
um but then the other part of me that's
so interesting is that i'm the widow of
ron plesser who was um a colleague who
david knew socially in washington and he
wrote part of the privacy act and the
foia the freedom of information act
so i my my brother and i are this
intersection between
secrecy and the intelligence community
on the one hand and then freedom of
information on the other hand and now
here we are in this christopher steele
thing and um in this age of information
and so i'd love to hear david talk about
um you know the balance between these
two things and just as an idea i would
love to see the pentagon and the cia
create an office of um creative
history or some kind of place where
writers like my brother and historians
could go and present their information
and get i don't know you know like a
seal of approval or something saying yes
this is valid this is not something like
that i i know you understand what i'm
saying and lastly i just want david to
talk about the new crop of journalists
that are coming up out of this um
russiagate thing that he's on television
with all the time and how great they're
doing these 30 and 40 year old
journalists and just talk about you know
becoming a patron to them or a mentor to
them barbara thank you for your time
this afternoon
so first i just have to say barbara it's
wonderful um to talk with you uh
via television your late husband ron as
you know i i really love ron plusser and
i i miss him as i'm sure you do he was a
wonderful man
um so many rich things and what you said
the story of your dad and his
adventures in the oss sound
extraordinary your brother's right to be
trying to pitch something to hollywood
because it sounds like a natural
i wish him uh good luck luck with that
and i i'll i'll look and see if i can
find the
unclassified summary of of this uh
operation that you described um just on
a couple of the of the points you you
made
the new journalists who were for the
washington post new york times other
news organizations um
doing aggressive coverage of
the russia
meddling story
and
this unusual um unprecedented presidency
uh
it's just fantastic to watch them work
it's this is a period where we really
have to be aggressive but we can't make
mistakes if if the news media makes big
mistakes makes us very vulnerable
to attacks so i just i love seeing
the
aggressiveness and the and the
professionalism of these uh kids i
michael schmidt from the new york times
to take not my paper but another one
just broke a couple days ago a fantastic
uh story about
the pressure
on attorney general sessions not to
recuse himself really broke some new
ground in this in this in this story
um you know he's just a young
hard-working smart person
the great thing is the more uh
you know wonderful examples of
journalism that we're generating the
more movies like the post which is out
now that people see the more smart
people come into our business we were
just you know really in contraction the
journalism was fading
and
i can remember wondering whether really
made a difference in the world a few
years ago
i don't wonder that anymore
i i every day when i get up i know i
know the value of what my colleagues and
i are doing so i think that's that's
great just a final thought about
how to use this expertise the things
that we know from our families from our
from our lives
my
friends at harvard i occasionally teach
at the belfor
center at the harvard kennedy school i'd
like to talk about applied history and
almost as a discipline of applied
history like we have applied mathematics
applied
different disciplines applied history is
a good one
where you look at the lessons the
experience that people had during the
cold war during any period in our
history and you think how do we apply
that to what we're living with now and
make better decisions i love that i
lay in a future life i'd love to be an
applied historian
well two of the people you listed as
being influenced by ben bradley and
catherine graham
what'd you think of the post movie i
thought the post movie was was wonderful
it was stirring it's almost a hymn to
my newspaper and uh and my my profession
so of course i i love it i thought what
was unforgettable about the movie was
the portrayal of mrs graham
i
am lucky enough to have joined the post
in 1986
to have known mrs graham well to have
interacted with her often i can hear her
voice you know when i would say
something particularly stupid she would
say
david you know
how could you uh she was just um she was
so funny she was so mischievous
uh meryl streep uh it's uncanny how she
captures
uh the little quirks the way she carried
herself
her voice it's just it's a brilliant
portrayal and it captures
the moment in which she became a great
uh a great owner great publisher uh when
she you know the business side said as
they had to this this could cost you
your business
and ben bradley
uh my boss my friend said as he had to
you gotta punish and mrs mrs g as i was
just callers had a tough decision to
make and she made the right decision and
on that decision has built
our
fantastic success as a
as a newspaper and also as a as a
company so
i love the i love the people want to see
the real characters who lie behind that
this wonderful
evocation there's an hbo documentary
about about ben bradley that
was
premiered about a month six weeks ago
it's still easy to find on hbo it's
narrated by ben himself ben
voiced his autobiography and it's um
check that out if you want to see ben
bradley shape my career i'm the
godfather of ben's youngest son
ben was
absolutely central to my
life and growth that ben kept trying to
hire me at the washington post and i
kept saying no in the early 1980s and
better finally said
i've done more to raise your salary than
you have because every time the post
would make an offer i go back to wall
street journal and they just offered me
this and i get a little more money but
uh you know these were i i what a what a
blessing to have lived in a period when
the real ben bradley and the real
catherine graham
stalked the earth roamed our newsroom
unforgettable well i think you uh
dedicate or thank don graham jr i think
it's a sun king maybe
so don
each of my books i i thanked don was
katherine graham's son
don
was our publisher don don literally
knew the names not just of every
reporter and editor but every press
operator every person who delivered the
paper and don
was
an owner the likes of which we we've
never seen he
had been raised to run the post
believed in it and he did the most
courageous thing
uh for which i think you know he doesn't
get
enough public credit so i just want to
say
don saw that his family and the
structure of the washington post is a
publicly traded company
just was not sufficient to keep the post
healthy enough to do the great
journalism that it needed to and so he
took this
thing that he loved as much as anything
in his life the washington post and he
found a buyer who would be able to run
it
at the level of investment
energy that it needed and that's jeff
bezos the the
founder of amazon who purchased the
washington post
on his own with his own
fortune who's been a fantastic owner for
us who gave us money and confidence and
the new this new era of the washington
post is is under just leadership but it
was don
who um you know did an assessment the
most unselfish thing of knowing that he
had to sell the paper
uh give up this thing that he'd love
that his mother had built
to keep it to keep it healthy to keep it
alive it's a great thing
evelyn clearwater florida please go
ahead with your question or comment for
david ignatius
well after i've listened to all these
brilliantly outstanding people i sort of
wonder whether i should even open my
mouth
however i will
first of all
i want to thank c-span for existing
i'm 88 years old
and
every weekend i turn on c-span
from
early friday until sunday night i have
something to watch
and the
facility in which i live which is a
senior facility
has told me that if i give them
a collection of books
they will order some special books
because i read weird books
weird books meaning books on
unlike um
the mystery books that
everybody is reading nora roberts etc
etc
i read weird books i want david
mccullough
ignatius
those are weird books
so i'm getting together a collection of
weird books
but my original question was
there are two things that i want to say
number one
i
wrote a book
nothing like david ignatius and it
didn't become a bestseller it was living
beyond darcel by date
and the reason i wrote that is because
everybody is in a rush to retire
and the truth is
that we do live beyond ourselves by date
because there really is not a lot
for older people to do
unless they've done something if you've
become a well-known writer or an artist
or have some particular skill
you really
are no longer needed
there's nothing for you at this
particular point
you are just
there and
it was interesting to me because i
didn't realize i read one of your books
and enjoyed it very much mr mc mr
ignatius
but many years ago my husband who was
not a reader
got on the train we were living in new
york and he got on the train to white
plains
and he struck up a conversation
and this man said he had just written a
book the spy that came in from the cold
and my husband said that's a strange
title
and he said to my husband yeah my name
is david cornwall
and he gave him his phone number and
said
why don't you call me and we can get
together
and my husband was a very as you can see
he wasn't a great intellectual
and he had never heard of the book
and never heard of the man when he came
home and told me i got all excited i
probably would have screwed up the
conversation because i probably would
have been so excited i wouldn't have
known what to say to him
but my husband
just didn't pay much attention
and never really followed through david
cornwall
alias john le carre went back to england
and
my husband never got in touch with him
and i continue to read his books i do
like spy books
i like your books
i know you don't think he was much of a
writer but i'm curious as to what sort
of writer you thought he was
what your opinion was of him evelyn
thank you for calling in and thank you
for watching book tv every weekend it's
48 hours of of books television for
serious readers david ignatius your
opinion of john le carre
um i
um i think john lecre is is a wonderful
novel some of my favorite
certainly spy novels uh are his his
books the smiley novels i think john
lecrae went through a period um over the
last uh 15 years maybe in which i didn't
enjoy his novels as much i thought they
were a little one-dimensional the
american characters in particular
just seemed like you know the face of
evil and
it was not not all that interestingly
drawn i just reviewed his latest book a
legacy of spies which i loved which is a
kind of tour of
uh his characters from the spy who came
in from the cold alec lemus other other
characters from
from that
peter willem is the central character
in this book and i recommend that uh
highly to to people i just want to say
one thing about what evelyn said which i
found quite
moving
the
role that c-span plays in giving people
a way to talk about intellectual
subjects to a way to talk about books
now happily
novels with the beginning of this of
this new show
is is so wonderful it's part of the
texture of american life that i i've
always
i've known brian lamb since he first
started c-span and i think it's just
such a get the idea of you being
in retirement wherever you are and
having a weekend that you know you can
look forward to where people will talk
and think that's great i always think
about when i when i retire the only
thing that really cheers me when i think
about is all the books i haven't read
yet
all the books that are still there to be
read so anyway i'll think about evelyn
and all the other people who were
in wherever they do their reading
watching c-span
this email from brad i remember hearing
some time ago that mr ignatius was
co-writing an opera about machiavelli
would mr ignatius comment on that
experience and tell us what the status
of that opera is
i'm happy to answer that question i did
write the libretto
for an opera called the new prince
which is
about machiavelli
set in
florence in 1512 but then set
in the future on the 500th anniversary
of the publication of the prince
and this opera the
music is written by muhammad faeruz a
wonderfully gifted young american
composer and it had its
world premiere in amsterdam with the
dutch national opera in march
of last year and i'm happy to say that
your humble librettist got to take
two
curtain calls to a standing audience
at the at the opera house in in in
amsterdam so that was
you know for me as a writer just a
kind of
you know
reach goal i i don't know much about
opera but i i have read machiavelli
i loved working on this of all the
pieces of writing i've done weirdly this
libretto is one of the things i'm i'm
proud of stuff
i hope i would love to be able to tell
viewers that this is going to be
uh shown in in america that some opera
companies provide uh i hope that'll
happen but not yet well one of the key
scenes in the quantum spy takes place in
a theater in amsterdam the theater is
richly described is there is there a
relationship that the theater in which
in which this takes place which is an
unpronounceable dutch word uh is in fact
the theater where my opera premiered
and uh i
still remember i had not heard the opera
i was terrified it was going to be a
flop of course
and i remember sitting there with
holding my wife's hand and practically
crushing the
bones in her hand because i was so
nervous
to see this but
yes the the opera house has an important
fictional role in the quantum spy
has there been a lead woman protagonist
in your books named eve yet i would
never dare
name a character after after my wife
eve
i do
let my some my characters wear
you know
suits
jackets
things that
she
i bought her at various
you know design
but they never look as good on the
character as they do on on each
gene is in hillsborough north carolina
and gene you're on book tv with david
ignatius
hi david
i was curious if you had
an idea of who might be the most likely
successful person as far as
our company as far as quantum computing
with
university or
maybe startup or big computer company
like ibm or
maybe a government contractor like lucky
what's your feelings for us where that's
going to end up going so as you may know
uh there are different companies
that are pursuing different pathways
to building a quantum computer the
companies are
the problem in building a quantum
computer is is
creating an environment in which the
qubits these you know particle bits that
are zero and one at the same time um
don't decohere in other words which they
last long enough to do some actual
computing that that ends up being
the biggest technical challenge there
are different pathways to doing that to
delaying
decoherence the ones that i studied most
carefully are
are microsoft's microsoft introduced me
to its
key
team members physicist michael friedman
at uc santa barbara
and others their idea is is to uh in
effect uh
braid the qubits in a kind of nanowire
in a in a in a in a material so that
they're more stable they can be shielded
better from the things that lead to
decoherence
heat
any kind of
energy that interferes
there's a different approach that the
university of maryland and some big
companies have chosen called the single
ion
pathway
i've been to see that at the university
of maryland that's fascinating they're
able to entangle to gather together more
qubits than some other
approaches every major company in the
i.t space and every major university
um is is involved in one consortium or
another yale has a big program like the
university of maryland uh it's it
the technical puzzles are so interesting
one one reason that i've become more
hopeful that
they'll actually succeed in building a
quantum computer is just there's so much
brain power now in the united states and
china around the world devoted to
solving the problems that you gotta
nuts you gotta crack to build one of
these computers but the simple answer to
your question is there are many
different pathways almost every big
company is involved in some way
peter lewiston maine email
work habits
how when how long a stretch
so uh there are two really three phases
of writing a novel for me the first is
research i'm now researching my next
novel my 11th novel so i'll do that
a couple times a week i'll i'll be going
off to interview somebody to gather
information for the book
thinking about about locations once you
really have the characters and the plot
set
the book takes over
i write two columns a week for the
washington post but
what begins to fill my
my
conscious pre-conscious my dream life
even is this
story that's taking shape in my mind you
fall asleep thinking about it you wake
up in the morning think about it you
dream a little bit about it it's just
and it crowds out everything else so
it's just it it's like a baby that wants
to be born it just it it
finds the nourishment it needs and so
other things just just have to
accommodate that and then finally
it took me a while to understand how
important this is there's the process of
editing and rewriting where you look at
the weaknesses of what you've done you
ask friends you ask my wife you know is
is this is this is this ready is this
there and if you know the people are
valuable say you know needs more work
needs help uh and and i think you need
to leave enough time as a writer to do
that rewriting to write not just the
second draft but the third in my recent
novels even the fourth draft so it's a
series of phases and i
uh steal time from from other other
parts of of life i hope readers of my
column it's not too obvious to them that
david must be working on a column
novel because these columns are a little
thin but uh but that does crowd out
other things you that you do
column twice a week yes
you didn't write a book from 1999 to
2007 you didn't publish a book from 1999
to 2007 but you've been kind of on a
two-year schedule
why
i moved to paris
in 2000 uh to become editor of the
international herald trivia which was a
dream job i'd always wanted to run a
newspaper
and here was a chance to run one in this
fabulous city we got i like to think the
nicest department in paris
uh on the send overlooking
next to the eiffel tower and i thought
david you would be an idiot
if you
well you have this incredible adventure
with your family my children were in
school then
if you
were a drudge and spending all your free
time writing a novel just give it up for
a little while and so i did
and we lived we had
a ball in paris but then when it was
when we moved back in 2004 it was time
to start again so i began working on
what became body of lies
next call is steve in ovid new york
steve
let me punch the button and now you can
go ahead and talk hi steve
oh oh hi david uh yeah hats off to
c-span because i was just skimming by
and i was just instantly captivated by
this subject and uh
if i was a newcomer to your material
um would you do me a favor and pick out
one of your books which
having read it would place me best to
enjoy the rest of them
and actually mac in dallas emails in the
same question so where to start so
you know as parents never like to
say who their favorite child is because
they don't they love every child
you feel that same way about your books
um that said uh if you want to get to
know my work
the right place to start is with my
first novel agents of innocence it was
published in 1987. like every first
novel i think the author
pours everything he knows about life
into the book
and so uh it's it's a book i'm proud of
it it's about the torments the middle
east there's not a word i'd change in
terms of you know what we've ended up
living through every year since 1987. so
i'd start there i i'm proud of
of all the books i think a firing
offense which is about a journalist
who gets entangled in cia operations is
a book i'm proud of i think body of lies
which made it into a movie
people still read and enjoy i think the
increment said in iran
is is a
book that takes you to a place that you
almost certainly never been so those
would be some some favorites but the
author would not be unhappy if you read
every one of them
do you reveal
the spies the
treachery the whatever
early on in your book or do you save it
for page 400
it it depends i i think um
over time i've learned that uh readers
of spy novels uh
like the
fun of the book turning
cartwheels in the last hundred pages and
doing a triple back flip in the last you
know 20 or 30 pages and so you need to
satisfy that so there needs to be some
surprises even where the reader thinks
he or she knows what's ahead they don't
quite know what's ahead
so i think that's that's important
um
the
i i do try to
think about the big plot points
carefully before i start
uh it always ends up being complicated
more complicated and different different
than that
but
you know i i'm a believer that books
like the ones i write are
meant to be entertaining i mean we're
not writing tolstoy here
you know this is this is not i'm i i
hope my books are good but this isn't
great literature these are spy novels
and they're they're written to entertain
so that i know what the pleasure of a
spy novel is it's it's you know it's
that funny mind game he did he just
didn't see it coming and so you want to
you and as i said earlier
it's it's the thing that makes you stay
out that extra 15 minutes so i want to
make sure i don't forget that don't get
too high-minded about this or that and
remember that i'm in the entertainment
business
but you also said that if you read one
of your books and you think you're
baking a cake you're going to end up
with a mud pie you said earlier but
you've assembled all the right
ingredients to make that cake haven't
you
so i've assembled um
ingredients that are
um
that are coherent that are plausible but
that doesn't mean that they're right
uh ben bradley my my beloved boss the
washington post used to say that
although we had a responsibility at the
post to write about intelligence matters
if they affected our readers
that we didn't necessarily need to write
about the wiring diagram details ben
used to use that phrase that we don't i
don't need to tell them a wiring diagram
and the wiring diagram is not typically
in my novels usually it's because i have
no idea what the wiring diagram is i
mean there are secrets that people hold
and if you tried to find out you
couldn't
so but but i but but the details that
are there are plausible i'm just saying
if you tried to combine them the way my
book says
you'd end up with a hodgepodge you know
hopefully on the page it doesn't seem
that way but uh it's so
roy
ellingford i hope i'm saying that right
elingford pennsylvania
i read tim weiner's legacy of ashes a
history of the cia
what is it about the romance of the spy
story that overcomes the sordid reality
and hopeless outcomes that continue to
fascinate readers and writers
um
i i think
the the things in tim's uh
account of the cia which which i don't
is not that's not the definitive history
certainly
um
that lead to the disasters are are
typically the covert actions where the
united states seeks to manipulate
another country and as i said earlier
the ability of military power or
intelligence operations to alter another
country in a way that
you know
works in the long run
not not a lot of evidence of that so i
think that's the the lesson of tim's
book is is about is about covert action
i think a better
account of that same theme is is evan
thomas's book the very best men which is
richly
reported with with character detail it's
just unforgettable about the people who
made that
understandable but but but misconceived
uh effort to manipulate other other
countries why does it continue to be
interesting um
first the people are interesting
the people who like to read military
history know that what makes a good
officer commander good
non-commissioned officers
certain qualities that are just
unforgettable when we read rick
atkinson's account of
world war
ii in europe i was saying to you earlier
peter when i read ian tolls the first
two volumes of his history of the war in
the pacific i come away with the
character of the commanders of the of
the younger officers i think of my dad's
stories of
what war is same thing with intelligence
work the the
um
dilemmas that people face the way they
operate the conditions under which they
operate the fear
that's just a
constant part of their of their lives as
they try to do that to do their work uh
interests me so the
i like to distinguish between my work as
a journalist a columnist where at the
end of 750 words i say
and so this is terrible you know or some
some declaratory judgment of what you
should think about it the end of a novel
i don't i don't have to do that i've
just described this world and you get to
make up your mind who you think that the
the villains are who you think i mean
you you paint on a bigger canvas so i
again i think that's one reason you come
back to it's because you're not making
the sort of um
declaratory judgment
thumbs up thumbs down you're just
describing
gordon port orchard washington please go
ahead
uh hello mr ignatius can you hear me yes
sir
oh thanks for uh taking my call
a little just a brief background
i'm a 77 year old retired marine
retired lawyer
um
led a infantry unit in vietnam back in
1968.
that's
probably irrelevant to my questions but
uh
you mentioned earlier some
political
matters that triggered my interest
and i understand you write a column
twice a week in my post
i haven't read the post for quite some
time
i'm probably going to start reading it
again read your columns because i'm very
impressed with your
your edition and
intelligence
but getting to the point um
maybe you'll have some comments
on
why
mrs clinton did not win uh last year
and to preface or to
add to that i did not vote for her
i did not vote for trump
i agree with your characterization as
our current polarization in this country
is almost
unbelievable
i characterize characterize myself as a
radical moderate that leans a little bit
right
but certainly not completely so to the
idiot sticks on the alt-right
but uh jordan we're going to get it
we're going to hear from mr ignatius and
we appreciate your calling in and
watching
well i'm i'm with i'm with gordon i'm
the uh the angry center uh or the
radical moderate that's that's uh where
i feel
um why didn't mrs clinton win
uh
i'd say
the beginning of the answer is that she
didn't the obvious she she didn't wasn't
able to present a program
of what where she would take the country
that was
compelling enough to overcome the
obvious weaknesses of donald trump as an
alternative
uh she she just she couldn't do that she
had a lot of negatives to begin with
a lot of people just didn't didn't like
hillary clinton
but
i i she never was able to build
sufficiently um
to to give people confidence that she'd
be a good leader for for our country to
give enough people
uh that that confidence i just say one
more thing i think the strategy that the
clinton campaign
adopted was to basically let donald
trump demonstrate
through his statements through his
behavior that he was unsuitable to be
present that he didn't temperamentally
have the right qualities to be a good
leader for our country and they they
thought that over time he basically
would reveal that and people would make
a rational judgment and decide that he
wasn't the right person
i think he did reveal that on
suitability
during the campaign we have seen in the
last year in his behavior as president
in my judgment a lot more about that
unsuitability about about the problems
of his of his of his temperament
that was before the country at the time
of the election
and i i do
we'll get through this this period the
institutions that keep america strong
are still pretty pretty powerful a lot
of momentum
for our country but i do worry that the
citizens of the united states are going
to have to take responsibility they're
going to have to make good judgments
there's nothing that we've learned about
donald trump's temperament
since he took office that we didn't
basically know on election day
and i think people didn't pay sufficient
attention to it they were too angry
about things or for whatever reason
so i think you know it's that's i just
my bottom line is we have to be good
citizens we have to be informed we have
to put the time in
to keep our country
strong
stable heading into the future if we
don't if we're just angry each other
our troubles are only going to get worse
from the sun king which came out in 1999
the author's note says
washington itself has become so
outlandishly unreal that any disclaimer
about a novel set in the nation's
capital should be redundant
so yeah i mean that was 1999 and it was
that was the time of the of the clinton
impeachment and the kind of crazy
we've had our periods of craziness each
each sort of like undamped oscillations
sort of like
you know the oscillation gets wider and
wider and the country gets crazier and
crazier i mentioned my dad earlier
and i know he's watching so he's gonna
he's gonna smile when i recall one of
his analogies for politics my dad talks
about a spinning top
and you think of a top spinning on a
countertop
and you can give a top a real knock you
know really
but if it's spinning fast enough it
comes back to the center point pretty
quickly
the problem is when it's not spinning as
fast as it should and then you give it
that knock and it wobbles more and more
and then eventually it falls over and my
dad is right
america is like a spinning top it
doesn't have enough spin i don't know
why that is but it doesn't have enough
spin it needs to spin faster it needs to
be more confidence to be more integrated
as a country
otherwise the knocks that we get
uh we're just seeing more wobble
email from mark i was wondering what
david thought of michael flynn what kind
of character he would make in a novel
he'd be a fascinating character uh in in
this sense he was head of dia mike flynn
was head of dia but that was not the the
apex of his of his career i first met
mike mike flynn
uh either in afghanistan or in iraq
probably in afghanistan but
um
mike flynn um
as an intelligence officer
j2
and as one of the people who drove the
fusion of intelligence that
in turn drove the
jsoc raids against al-qaeda and iraq the
zarqawi
leadership
was really an innovator
they found a way to
you know
hit a target extract the intelligence
in that 24 hour cycle
analyze the intelligence the cell phones
the computers the you know
flash drives
and then know where to strike the next
night and then again pound more
intelligence pound and mike flynn was
was um at the center of that he was an
outstanding officer
uh i remember meeting him in afghanistan
hearing his his comments about about
good ideas about about what to do to be
more effective in that war something
that i've noticed my whole career is
that people who spend their lives
in super secret parts of the government
and when mike flynn was a military
officer he typically was in one of our
super secret task force operations that
don't even disclose their you know their
names or locations
when those people come out
of the super secret
environment into something more open
they often don't have good judgment
about what to say and what not to say
i saw that
mentioned james angleton who i met at
the beginning of my career when he came
out of
the darkest recesses of the cia but he
couldn't stop talking and that's true
with a lot of these people and i think
that general flynn as much as people
should respect what he did in his
military career in these more open roles
running dia
wasn't really a success and then as he
became a political figure in the
campaign he you know
all we need to do is look at what he
pleaded guilty to um in
in his recent plea agreement with
with the
special counsel mueller so but i think
there's a there's a deeper point about
uh
our the secret parts of our government
cia nsa
the military's military units need to be
ventilated more people need more
exposure
so that they'll make better judgments
and then
when they come out
that they'll that they'll have more
more success
a few minutes left with our guests david
ignatius and david is in wynwood
pennsylvania david you're on the air
i'm so glad i got in uh i very much
appreciate what you just said about the
general flynn mr ignatius
i've been involved with israel all my
adult life
and i've used on many occasions a quote
which i believe is from you which i saw
in a documentary
to the effect that
anti-semitism is the elevator music of
the arab world
am i right in attributing that to you
and if so do you still believe it
you know i i i that sounds like
something that i that i said in the past
i'm not sure exactly where but it's it's
it is a fact
that anti-semitism has been
too common uh too easily accepted too
unchallenged in the arab world for as
long as i've been traveling there i hope
that that's that that's changing in
countries like the uae even saudi arabia
uh where you used to hear
people say things that would make you
make your hair curl uh that that that
that's
beginning to to change i i do think that
the problem
uh in so many of these
countries is that people didn't speak
out and challenge
um what was a sort of strident
uh anti-israel rhetoric that did
sometimes verge on uh it's not it's not
israel it's the jews who were to blame
and people needed to call that out uh
you can have views about israel's
actions
and i've written critically about some
things that israel has done but but
that's not the same as this sort of
uniform
unceasing
criticism so i can't i can't give you a
citation for having said that but i'm
i'm not disagreeing that that it's true
that there is a kind of elevator music
constancy to that rhetoric that always
bothered me
when you talk about official
non-official and integrated covers
for cia agents what are we talking about
so uh official cover is you're the
political officer at the usm embassy in
in in harare or in in in cairo are you
presumed to be cia are you rci so you
are ci officer uh you're often declared
is the term of arts so this this
cia station chief
in uh whatever city it is in paris
london cairo will go to the head of
their security service and declare
who were the ci officers and often
they'll be the ones who conduct the
official liaison so they'll travel off
into the other country's
intelligence headquarters and they'll
sit down and and talk non-official cover
is somebody who's traveling for xyz
trading corp
uh and you know he's got a home office
in buffalo and he's got a branch office
in
dubai and uh he's got a you know
business cards and a whole kind of
backup that says he works for xyz
company but he's actually a private
company but he's actually an
intelligence officer under non-official
cover those people are often described
as knox taking the initials noc
um integrated cover often refers to
people who whose
cover jobs
have been carefully prepared so that
they all the benefits so
let's say somebody is a is a consular
officer and it's uh
integrated cover where the person is
doing real consular work if you try to
you know scratch that you got suspicious
you'd find that there was
uh backup all all the way all the way
down
um you know these cover issues are are
interesting that the really interesting
issues
today in the in the era of
you know digital footprints every move
we make is being recorded by a camera
somewhere
every time we cross a a
national frontier
our biometrics our fingerprints our
retinas digital retina skin
are taken how do you move people
secretly across borders
you know in a world where their real
identity no matter what it says on the
passport
is known to of
aggressive
competent foreign intelligence service
that's an interesting puzzle
my it's one of the things i'm
researching for the future
i i can guess at some of the answers but
i think that's
this question of your digital exhaust as
people in the intelligence world
sometimes say and how you vacuum it up
how you deal with a world where others
are capturing your digital exhaust
that's a a real-life
2018 spy problem well
in the past 30 years your books have
moved into the cyber world very very
extensively i decided uh two books ago
that every theme of the spy novel
uh penetration manipulation uh just go
down the list of the things that
was going to zeros and ones was going
digital that that's that was where
uh espionage and intelligence lived now
and that it was time for me to kind of
realize that and recognize it so i in
the director two novels ago i i went to
the hackers convention called defcon in
las vegas and just hung around with
hackers and and watched them talk about
how you you know how you break into
servers and how you i've never forget
you know walking into this conventions
las vegas there's a big screen scrolling
that's got in real time the the names
usernames and passwords of every account
that's being hacked of everybody that
that's there in real time it was just
stunning and uh so i
my new novel i'm working on also has
these themes i just think this is where
the spy business lives now and if you
want to write spy novels uh that are you
know that are that are about the real
world that people are operating and this
is where you got to go chuck carbondale
illinois hi chuck
hi
um i have a real simple question it goes
like this what's the difference between
uh
the russia of today
and the china of today the federal
government
and is there a flavor between the two
of how the handle asked you that
i'm going to hang up the phone now and
listen to your answer chuck thank you
for that
that's a great uh question um
we know from uh our
just historical reading and from spy
novels
uh about the meticulous tradecraft that
the russians have used the
russian intelligence has been the
mother's milk of of russian operations
going back to the czar's time
we write about fake news and meddling
and russian manipulation
russians were buying up newspapers
newspaper reporters again in the czar's
time and in the time of the early soviet
uh services so we understand how they
they operate
uh they're they're meticulous they stage
their operations with great care the
chinese were always thought to have a
kind of
more distanced
approach it was often said the chinese
wouldn't
try to plant the mole in the top of the
adversary's service as the as the
soviets so brilliantly did
that they would gather a thousand grains
of sand that was the phrase that
analysts often would use and that from
those thousand grains of sand they would
assemble a mosaic that showed the
picture of their adversary well
they haven't been true once but not
anymore the chinese now are very
aggressive as i said earlier in the show
there's a series of cases in which the
chinese have sought to recruit
people in our intelligence community not
necessarily chinese
ancestry they've gone you know gone for
the
the the
targets that really will pay off and
there's every indication that they're
going to do that even more aggressively
so
i think uh looking at china
understanding how their intelligence
service operates understanding how they
play the influence game as they become a
richer
country they're in a position to shape
political events
in countries that matter to them
australia has just issued a fascinating
report on the counterintelligence threat
that is posed by china
the threat that the chinese will
manipulate australian politics and
society that's to to to keep your eye on
for the past three hours david ignatius
has inaugurated our 2018 fiction edition
of in depth and we appreciate your time
thank you his books
first
published in 1987 was agents of
innocence
siro came out in 1991 the bank of fear
in 1995
a firing offense 1997 the sun king in 99
and then body of lies 2007 the increment
2009
blood money 2011 the director in 2014
and his most recent is the quantum spy
next month on in-depth uh
national book award winner and pulitzer
prize winner colson whitehead will be
our guest
well every month for the past 20 years
one of